Here we go. Four, three, two,
boom. George Lockhart, John Kavanagh,
how white folks those sir. Great.
Good to see you. Good to be
here. Um, so Saturday night,
what are your thoughts now that we're
sitting here? It's Monday morning.
The Khabib Mcgregor fight went down
Saturday night and obviously hugely
disappointed. Yeah. You can
get the results from the
night. I still enjoyed it.
I tell it was a great fun. I'm looking
forward to watching it back many times.
All the corners fights.
I always pull it out of the lessons
away that I can pass it on to the next
generation of guys.
But yeah,
overall I really enjoyed the fight and
I'm devastated that we didn't get there.
Yeah. How much time did he have
to prepare for this fight? Um,
I mean he's always in the gym. He's
always, he's always knocking about,
but I guess it was official a 10 weeks,
10 weeks out.
But even since the 85 I kind of knew,
or at least I taught this next MMA fight,
would be happy to just,
just kind of made sense if it
wasn't going to be the Diaz.
But then as time went on that
that seemed less and less likely.
And Habib obviously he was doing
great, you know, kept on winning.
So where is it a pot that
was going to collide?
Was there anything that was
surprising in the fight? Um,
the, the, the right hand and the second
round was, it was a cracker was beautiful.
Overhung right. I mean it's
a, it's a staple of wrestlers,
overhand right and close,
but he doesn't generally do
like more job and then close.
But that was a great shot.
And this style of takedowns
everything was planned out,
what we expected. And we spent a lot
of time in preparing for that. Um,
yeah, just I, I, you know,
kind of expected round warm for sure.
Going to get a take down.
So the goal of round wound was to get
out of it. It's still having energy.
We do month to put a huge amount of
effort into trying to get back open room
warm.
We've seen that happen many times in his
or her opponents and to kind of go back
to the stool, you know, really tired.
So ran one, make them pay, you know,
do our best on the way in
fight as hard as we can.
But if we do end up down in
which it was against the fence,
figured it would be there and tried to
stay seized up. If we end up in our back,
just tried to play guard until,
until it, until the Bell,
except it will be a ten nine round
for round two again,
same,
same plan and do as much damage as we can.
But we ended up on our back at don't put
a huge amount of effort and trying to
get up.
He's an absolute master,
a regrounding people and that turned
out to be a ten eight round. You know,
he got some good shots there and obviously
he landed the greater right hand.
So that was a bit more than we hoped for.
Ronald treating started kind,
turning it a little bit in our favor
and we did a lot better at keeping it in
the middle. Defending the takedowns to
the plan was to slow him down a little.
I would watch him slow down a little bit.
And the third, fourth and fifth. Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
So I think I at the beginning to the
consensus was conex amount in the first or
her be, you know, takes over
from to on like first the wind,
the third round was probably a bit of
a surprise to people. But um, you know,
you know, dollar acquaint, the fight,
if you look at that for mountain freon,
he wasn't able to hit any take
downs. Um, so hoped that we have,
we'll go around tree,
we could defend the takedowns a lot
easier and start landing air shots and,
and that did happen for round tree,
not as well as I as we
plan as well as we hoped.
And then a around for, you know, we
hit another great takedown. [inaudible]
made a mistake giving up the over hook,
exposed our back.
And that was all she wrote.
Yeah.
He has such a unique ability to tie
both legs up with his legs. Yeah.
So I'm around one, I thought cognitive,
well, we practice for that, for a,
to keep our legs bent.
You know,
you see guys who straighten
their legs and then from,
and Connor did do that a couple of times,
but he was able to
continuously get a leg free.
So not until the last 30
seconds or so around one.
He didn't really tie them up and get
him flat on his back for the majority of
that he was against the fence, you
know, used his hands to keep upright.
Tried to learn a little
shots. Um, yeah. And George,
you, uh, you dealt with
Connors, wait, cut.
You deal with this
overall nutrition as well?
Yes sir.
Pull that microphone calls.
Do you like that you can move it up if
you want to be where you were taking?
Hey guys, it's a, it's a
work in progress. You, uh,
you work with them on his weight cut.
Like what,
what was his weight before he
started camp? Um, you know,
it's almost exactly the same way.
Uh,
it was when we actually
started the cut. Um, you know,
we want to make sure that his way was
a little higher than, uh, you know,
obviously with the boxing, with
Floyd, you know, speed is everything.
And we wanted to kind of slowly
drop that way down, but with this,
want to keep them as big as possible
and then we'll cut all that weight so he
can, what was his weight? He was about
one 71 when he got back from to that cage.
So. So what was his weight when
you to start started camp? Uh,
about that same thing? Same
thing. Exact same thing. Yeah.
It was all about extreme
way. Cut. No pounds. Yeah.
In terms of cutting,
it was an easy day.
What's the most you've ever had
someone cut? Um, so you know,
on record with drew Dover,
he showed up at one 85 on Tuesday
and had to make one 55 by Friday.
So 90% of his body weight that we had it.
Yeah.
That's the biggest one. Biggest
one on record. He's a big fellow.
I've always looked at drew dober and go,
how the fuck is that guy? Make one 55,
right? No. Every time I see him
I'm like, you know, yeah, you're,
you're making me work my, you
know, we're from my money. Yeah.
Well it seems like it's probably not the
healthiest thing in the world for him
to do either. No, I mean, I'll
never, I'll never be like, you know,
weight cutting is the easiest thing in
the world. But I will say that like,
because the amount of muscle mass,
people look at somebody like
him and they're like, mommy,
he doesn't have a lot to lose and
he doesn't have a lot to lose,
but he's got a lot to cut. A
muscle is about seven, you know,
muscle tissues about 79% water,
so more,
and most of you have the more
water you can cut, you know,
so if you do it properly, uh,
the more most of you have,
the easier it is for that cut.
And that's why he's able to do that.
How did you learn how to do this?
Honestly, man, I'm like, I'm,
I can be like, well, I got this
degree and I got this degree,
but there's no degree in actual
weight cutting. You know,
I started in the Marine Corps and, uh, uh,
I was a heavyweight when I started
fighting and then I ended up as a
welterweight and, um, wow. Yeah, yeah.
It didn't do so well as a welter weight.
Kind of the opposite of Anthony Rumble
Johnson. Right, right. You know,
it's definitely not, uh, it wasn't,
it didn't work out well for me.
I was better at cutting the weight
then I was actually at fighting.
But I'm learning through this
process, okay, this, this,
this works like this and this works
like this. And there's, I mean,
there's so many studies, uh,
the route there, you know,
like you look at the NSCA,
you look at, you know, uh, uh,
pub med and all these other things.
You,
you see a study over here and you see
a over here and you're like, okay,
well we're going to put these two together
and actually see in terms of actual
weight cutting it,
it's,
it's rough because nobody's ever actually
going to do a study with the level of
dehydration that these guys are
doing. You're like, oh yeah, this,
this how you rehydrate these people. It's
never, it's never going to happen. So,
you know, luckily we've, uh, you
know, the amount of cuts that we did,
we work with over 200 UFC fighters. And
just, just, I mean, just in UFC, I mean,
obviously we work with a lot more like
a bill tours, stuff like that. But, uh,
being able to see that, okay,
this works, this doesn't work.
We need a kind of bankers.
And you say you work with them.
If you work with 200 fighters, how hands
on are you with 200 different fighters?
Um, it changes, you know,
based on, um, you know, how,
how much they need us. You
know, a lot of the guys,
we literally don't show up until
the week of the fight. You know,
somebody like Connor, you know,
I'm out there six to eight weeks,
I'm out there and monitor and
everything and um, you know,
the people that we are out
there for, for, for eight weeks,
it makes life a lot easier.
You do you have anything to do
with his meal planning as well?
Like during the camp corner? A
hundred percent, hundred percent.
And that goes into his mouth.
I'm, I'm, I'm monitoring like,
so from the moment you guys
start in camp hundred percent.
What about outside of camp? Does he
taking instruction from you? Yeah,
corner. You know, he needed
me and be like, Hey, I'm
doing this, you know, like a,
in terms of like workout, that's a big one
for him. Like, oh, they're pre workout,
post workout. Well,
what should I be taking?
I tell him exactly what he should
be taken. And then, um, you know,
basically stays on a regimen.
And I think Damien like diet,
the word Diet means Fujita habitual way.
And uh,
I liked guys to actually live life a
little bit, you know what I'm saying?
And when you're, when you're so
regimented, like, okay, I gotta,
I gotta count this car, but I got to count
this. And again, it's, it's ridiculous.
You know what I'm saying? So, you know,
the fact that he actually is like, okay,
I just, I just need a monitor
what I'm taking pre, post workout.
It makes life easy for me.
Did you go to school for nutrition
or even in the Marine Corps?
I was a combat conditioning specialist.
I was actually instructor trainer.
So like, um, when you go,
there's this place called martial arts
center of excellence. Right. And, uh,
they actually hand picked marines,
um,
kinda been through, you know, like in, you
know, certain situations in the military.
Uh, Brian Stan was a, was actually,
you know, a part of that. And then, uh,
they actually started something called
the combat conditioning program.
And I was actually the,
the,
the guy that they actually
had to teach all that.
So they sent me everywhere, like
a, I got to work with the, uh,
the people from the
Olympic training center.
I get to work with a Pi and a
Florida, you know, like, um,
just learn from a lot of different people.
But in terms of like,
I will say this from weight
cut and there's actually not a,
like there's not a course, like if you're
a Dietitian or whatever, that's good.
That's great. But that doesn't help
you with in terms of weekend, right?
You go to somebody who's like, hey man,
I'm going to lose 30 pounds in three days.
What do I do?
You know,
it's a very specific kind of discipline.
So it's something that you kind of have
to learn along the way and no one's
going to teach you in a school 100%.
You do have a back,
some sort of background in nutrition.
Oh, 100%. Yeah, absolutely.
Does,
do you vary your diets based on the way
guys train or is it like pretty standard
or does it vary depending on how
much weight they have to lose?
Every diet is different. Like, I mean,
people like themselves never
get the same diet twice, uh,
the same person.
Um,
so like if you wake up at six o'clock in
the morning versus eight o'clock in the
morning, you have to have a totally
different diet. You don't like,
we feed people from the moment
they wake up to the moment.
What would be the dose?
Say someone likes to get up at six o'clock
in the morning versus someone let's
get it up at eight. Would it be in
what time they have to train that?
Would that be the, the
variables one variable? Well,
we base everything off
tight, uh, tight timing,
portion size or homeowner responses of
foods. You know what I'm saying? Like, uh,
uh, most diets nowadays, they
actually, you know, they, they,
they kind of stick to one
aspect like Atkins Diet.
It sticks the types of foods, you
know, like a zone diet is portion size.
We actually stick to all of them, you
know, like type timing, portion size,
women responsible. Because, you
know, if you look at all diets,
they all work. All diets will
work. You know, like if you're,
if you're consistent to every single diet,
if you do the same thing every
single day, you, you're sick,
you're going to see results.
But are you going to get to a specific
weight and is your performance going to
be, Eh, you know, increased
over a fight camp, you know,
that that's when nutrition becomes,
you know,
v extremely valuable.
What would be the difference between
someone getting up at six and someone
getting up an eight time they eat? You
know, so if somebody wakes up at six,
they're going to eat it at six o'clock
in the morning. So I'm gonna get seven,
eight, they're going to eat at eight
o'clock in the morning. We feed them.
You have them, you have a meeting as soon
as they wake up. Absolutely. Yes sir. You,
you feed somebody till the moment they
woke up to the moment they go to bed.
What would be a typical
breakfast meal? We, we, we,
we live off the basic rule you give,
uh,
give people what they need when
they need it. So, you know,
if you're a Robic right and your body's
primary source of fuel is going to be
more fats,
uh,
your brain's primary source of fuel is
going to be a carbohydrate or glucose,
right? So we give them like
a lot of fruits, right?
The glucose feed, the brain,
a lot of fats. You know, we
made sure that we, you know,
we get a good measurement of
Omega threes, Omega Sixes, um,
basically a better about a two to one
ratio. So throughout today, you know,
if they're, if they're are throughout
the day, we give them, you know,
fruits, vegetables, um, Omega
six, Omega threes. And then when,
once they start working out,
then, you know, depending
on the workout, then that's,
we started giving like more
starches and stuff like that.
So basically just sort of
a light breakfast of fruits
and things on those lines
to get everything moving.
And then after your first workout,
like what's a typical postworkout meal?
I, it depends on the actual workout.
We use something called like, you
got the metabolic equivalent, right?
So basically the met is the amount
of oxygen and your body uses.
And that that's going to
determine basically, uh,
the amount of calories that your body,
so let's say a strength
and conditioning workout,
what if they're going to do weights and
sprints and things along those lines.
So what we'll do is everything
is actually like a formula.
Everything is, everything is broken
down mathematically. So we'll take a,
they're met and we'll,
we'll go on a scale of one to 10 and we
multiply that by the actual amount of
weight that that individual has,
like a kilogram. So we'll say, um,
their intensity is a 10.
Let's say they have a hard workout,
tends you to have Tammy. We multiply
that by the amount of kilograms, um,
that that individual has a, I
believe. And then look at the formula.
We basically divide that by a 200 and
multiply that by the duration I actually
work out.
And that'll give us the amount of
actual calories that that individual is
actually using for that workout.
So every workout is going to be different.
So if you're, if you're,
if you're doing, um, like,
what's the word I'm looking for?
Like training in terms of like
guard passing and stuff like that,
it's going to be a lot different
than if you're sparring, right?
So a lot of people, they actually, they
feed themselves the same way. If they're,
if they're doing form versus actually
training like sporing you don't they,
they do the same thing I'm going to take
to, you know, in two scoops, protein,
I would take this, this
and this. You have to,
you have to actually feed the
body differently every single,
every single workout, right? So
we'll take that formula. We find out,
okay,
this amount of calories
that this individual burns
during this period of time,
and then we actually break it down even
more because if you jog and you burn a
thousand calories, right? And if you
lift and burn a thousand calories,
same amount of calories,
but you have to refuel the
body differently because
if you jog by just using a
lot more fat,
and if you're,
if you're lifting and your body's
getting a lot more carbohydrates, again,
it goes to giving the body what it needs
when it needs it. So we'll look at it.
I'm like, okay, well if it's a
level 10 and then we'll literally,
when we had the formulas for
word, so a 10 would be a 80, 20.
So you, you find out the amount of
calories is universal is burning and 80,
20 meaning 80% carbohydrates,
20% proteins, right?
And as you go to carbohydrate,
mostly francophone,
so your body has some called a know,
you have receptors in the
body, right? People think that
like, well, you know, if I,
if I,
if I need carbohydrates,
my body is just going to ingest them
and it doesn't work like that. Um,
your body can process about one gram
of carbohydrate per minute, right?
But if you are able to actually
access more, uh, actually, um,
use more than one, um,
transport, um, at a time,
you can actually go to about
two, three, 2.3 grams per minute.
And a, yeah, you have
good one, two, three,
four and you get as good one as glue to,
it's one of these has a different thing
that actually activate them. Right?
And I can ask you too, is, is a solely
independent transporter, right? If you,
if you use a sodium dependent transporter,
goof for us is a insulin dependent
transporter. A good one is a,
I believe, um, and I'm sorry.
Good five is a frutose. Uh,
it's activated by Frutose,
right?
So if you use more than one of
these transporters at a time,
you activate these transporters.
There were literally you're able to
actually synthesize carbohydrates twice as
fast. So you're doing different types of
carbohydrates and mixing them together.
Hundred percent. Group One, uh,
as good one is a solo
independent transporter.
So you gotta make it solely independent.
You got to make sure that you add sodium,
right?
Who for his insulin
dependent transporters,
what's going to help a
insulin be transported? You,
you need something that's high-glycemic.
So something that's dextrose.
But what is like a food?
That's a good one. Um,
well salt break down
salt and then a glute,
a glute five or a glue five would
be a fruit toast, which be fruit,
right? So we you don't offer,
I'll a break down fruit for him.
And then dextrose is, is basically
like in Tampa, sugar as you have,
you know what I mean? So, uh,
as basically we incorporate sugar,
fructose and salt. You put those together.
Now the funny thing is,
is when you incorporate caffeine,
it's been shown that
caffeine postworkout you'll,
you'll see four times the amount
of glycogen in the muscle,
a post workout. If you take
the, uh, the caffeine. Yeah.
Take it in the form of caffeine
pills or do you take coffee?
I'll incorporate it with like, uh,
the, the postworkout, you know,
like a coffee shop. Yeah.
It's, uh, anhydrous like a,
it's a, it's a stronger type.
Sometimes I'll see like, okay, if he's,
if he's obviously going to bed later and
it'd be more of a green tea type, uh,
caffeine. But yeah, I mean,
the funny thing is like,
it's shown that caffeine postworkout four
times the amount of carbohydrates are
in the muscle. And I have
yet to find out why. I,
you know, I talked to
Andy, a Gal Galton Yep.
Yeah. Do it. I love the guy. I'm like,
yeah, you know, so I'm like, Bro,
I want to get you in the room for like an
hour and just talk to you. Um, but, uh,
I was like, and I asked him and he's
like, honestly, I don't know either.
And I'm like, Shit. You
know what I mean? So, uh,
but you know, the thing is, I don't
know why, but the one thing I do know,
yes, 100%, you know, caffeine postworkout
everybody's all about, you know, caffeine.
Preworkout caffeine. Postworkout is, is
extremely important. And with our support,
it's so important because you got guys
that are working at two or three times a
day, you know, they need to be
rehydrated. They need their,
their glycogen storage is the,
they need to be up.
So did you essentially learn how to
wake up by cutting weight yourself?
I learned every, every way. Not to
wait. God by myself. Rehydrating yeah,
same way.
Uh, yeah, the, the rehydration I, I
did through you, you know, like lots,
lots of studying, lots
of studying. You know,
when I look back at what
I did for rehydration, I
shaved my head. I'm like, oh,
Uli, crap. Well, it's a
relatively recent thing, right?
When you think about it with wrestling,
I mean,
wrestlers didn't do such a good job
of rehydrating and they were basically
competing the day of the weight cut.
And you sound like it's past tense.
They still do.
They're trying to be a little bit better
about that with the way they allow
people with hydration tests and
colleges. And you know, it's still,
it's still rough, but at least
with them, there's no head trauma.
That's it. That's the big thing about
MMA is rehydrating with head trauma.
How much more difficult
is your job now with a,
you saw in place where they can't use ivs?
I love not having to ivy man. Really
swear to God. Yeah. Why? Um, you know,
if you look at every study out there,
like the oral rehydration is
actually better for the body.
Everybody's so funny nowadays, everybody's
like, oh, you don't like organic,
you know, earth grown nutrients get
to have this, you gotta have this.
And then when it comes to like
cutting weight, it's like,
now let's jam a into a freaking body on
this shove 9,000 milligrams of sodium
chloride in their freaking
veins. And that's gotta be
good. You know, if, if, uh,
if they were fighting the same day at
100% of the, yeah, you need an Ivy,
but they have over 30 hours
to rehydrate the body,
the body can do that on its
own and it's going to be a lot.
He's a lot more natural in terms of
absorbing nutrients and giving it what it
needs.
Here's the thing,
when a lot of these guys could I
break it down like this is the amount,
exact amount of sodium that
your body needs. A lot of,
a lot of people they will taking
in like to uh, to uh, bags of Ivs,
right? One bag is 9,000
milligrams of sodium chloride.
They would take in 82 bags that 18,000
milligrams of sodium chloride and they
wouldn't take any, any potassium.
Your bodies is, it's got to have a,
it's a balance of everything. Yeah. Yeah.
You're like, oh, you know, like Omega six,
like you look at fats,
you're like,
there's so many studies that
the Omega six is bad. You know,
like it causes all this
inflammation and stuff like, yeah,
Omega six does cause inflammation.
Your but you buy it needs it, your ear,
it needs it.
Your Oregon's needed,
but it needs a good amount of Omega three
to kind of clear that out. Same thing.
Sodium needs potassium. You know
like when you look at a muscle pump,
he like sodium goes in to a muscle,
potassium comes out.
Well how does potassium and get back
in? Well in these magnesium, magnesium.
And if you don't have magnesium you
have to have this, this balance.
And it's funny because these guys were,
you know,
back in the day they would take an
ivy and then, and then when they have,
they'd have soup and they're like, oh I
need to take more salt. They would never,
basically, you look at the amount of
potassium now these guys were like,
Hey George, what are, what do
I take? And I'm like, okay,
eat this. He does, he takes,
and I think it's a lot healthier for them.
So they're getting more
sophisticated with it. Oh,
Johnny Hendricks recently said that one
of the reasons why he retired is because
of you saw that and they could, they
wouldn't let them use the ivys anymore,
but he said it made a big difference
with him. Yeah. There's, um,
there's a lot of people that are in this
job dough that they have no business
being in this job doing what I do.
Like, I mean, I just got our shoes,
I've talked to him. How many people
like you are there out there?
I know there's chairing.
Yeah. And there's, um,
there's a nutrition and I think
perfecting athletes, things like that.
Um, I've, I've talked to a couple
people, you know, like, oh, you don't,
at the end of the day, man, honestly, I
always tell people, I'm like, you know,
I told my wife this. I'm like, you know,
a game is babe. And she's like, what?
I'm like, it's your ability to present
that you could give a fuck. Right.
And I'm like, and I'm like, you don't,
real game is, it's actually given a fuck.
You know what I'm saying? Like there's
a lot of people that they are like, oh,
I want to help you. I don't want to help
you out. You know what I'm saying? Like,
and people were actually like,
oh cool.
But then they realize that and that's
why they work with us cause they,
we actually give a fuck. Like we care,
you know, and you sit there and just like,
um, we talked, you know, like
were we, we were working with, um,
a Gray Jackson? Well it was, it
was, uh, it was Jonny bones and um,
it was a fight or whatever. And, and, and
I'm like, I'm like, hey guys, you know,
like obviously we work with DC and DC.
He's got exclusivity with us. I'm like,
how's he doing with the rehydration? Like,
oh, he's using the rehydration. I'm like,
dude, the rehydration I gave you
guys was before the IB ban like this.
It's not the same. And like, Oh, you
think you talked to his nutritionist?
So wanting to talk to him. And I
was like, you know, I was like, oh,
what's the osmolality of the,
the water that you given him?
And he looked to me like I had to
dig around my forehead and I'm like,
well how much fucking salt you
give? And I'm, he's like, Whoa,
I'm not giving them salt. I haven't
given him salt. There's dark, you know,
fucking training camp. Why
would I give himself and I,
I wasn't going to sit down and give him
a fucking whole lecture on nutrition but
like how the fucking body works or
anything like that. But um, I was like,
I just, I went to Johnny bones and I said,
bro, fucking start eating fucking salt.
Like your life depends on her brother
because I mean basically the muscle
contraction that you have,
a lot of it depends on the amount of
sodium that your body has. You know,
the amount of glycogen absorption,
muscle contraction neurons in the body,
it's all dependent on fucking salt. And
when you got guys that are like, wow,
you know, if I can no salt, I
think a lot of guys were in this,
in this game because they want their
name on the fucking highlights and shit
like that.
And you'll see me.
Well, it's real bizarre that this
is such a gigantic sport. Yeah.
I mean it's an enormous sport.
But in terms of even the way people train,
it's,
I mean, no one really, there's
not a consensus on what's the,
what's the correct way to do it.
And then when it comes to nutrition,
there's not a consensus.
Right.
And then there's the rehydration and
dehydration factor that doesn't exist in
any other sport other than than boxing.
Right. I mean this is the, Oh and,
and I think it's more extreme in MMA than
it is even in boxing for the most part.
Right.
It's just,
it's such a crazy thing that you've got
these super high level athletes that are
dealing with Jim Burrows.
I mean there's a lot of bro,
like real high level athletes and I've
talked to their trainers and I'm like,
what did you just say? Like you're a
gym, Bro. How'd you get with this guy?
This guy's a fucking world class fighter
and he's got some Schmo from fucking
Gold's gym. No offense, Gold's
gym. But you know what I mean?
Some fuckers guys got a tub of
shit with them. And he's like,
got to take three days and $4
because I read about it in Weeder.
You know what I mean?
They don't really have a strict protocol
and it's not really based on science
and blood work and,
and real science.
No,
100% like it's,
it's sad because the sport is at the
end of the day. Like they'll be like,
well that guy's jacked you the strength
and conditioning coach. He'd be like,
he's fucking biggest fuck you. Look. Yeah,
you shouldn't get it. You know, like,
and like, oh, you know, a couple
of people. You're now my agent.
You know what I mean? Like it's,
it's, you know, like in terms of NFL,
like we with him,
you know,
we work with a lot of different
people that we, you know,
we Demi Lavato and shit like that. Like
he's this close to your first, sorry,
sorry. Everybody does it.
So I'd rather than sorry.
And I know my voice is
there. People are like, good,
you got to have subtitles on this.
It's not the year. Is
this the model? Remember
Anderson Silva got popped and then
people started circulating photos of
Anderson's trainer. He's seven years
old. Built like a brick shit house.
I mean it's got veins coming
out of his fucking muscles.
They're just like garden hoses. Have
you ever seen him? No. It's hilarious.
When we found out that Anderson
got popped for steroids,
then they saw a picture of his train. I'm
like, wow, I wonder where he got them.
He see if you find you got a photo of
the guy is a picture of him taking a
Selfie at the gym? No,
no. That's not the guy.
This strength and conditioning guy.
He's fucking Jack.
He's a a darker gentlemen and he's
built like a brick shit house.
He looks more like a bodybuilder and he
does a strength and conditioning coach.
You got it? Yeah. Here it is.
I'm the guy with the white shirt on. Yeah,
that's him. But that's not the photo.
I want dairy his
day and he's, he's in his sixties
wow. Yeah, so you see that? Oh well
that's what I was without my
shirt. I believe you will.
Something going on there,
few south of the border
supplements. Uh, but you know,
but the point is that even like the
best of the best world class fighters,
they don't necessarily have a background
in nutrition or kinesiology or exercise
physiology.
Don't necessarily know exactly the way
to the right way to approach things.
I mean, shit, for years, fighters wouldn't
even drink water in between rounds.
Right. You know, I mean,
they thought water made you cramp and
there's a lot of like crazy shit involved
in this sports still to this day.
You don't know what you
don't know. And, and uh,
I tell you our goals by
the end of next year,
we're going to work with every
single fighter in the UFC.
We have over 200 fighters in the
UFC right now. Every single one.
So you're going to push everybody
else out. Fuck off and fuck everybody.
Fuck everybody. 100% man. You know, what
are they doing wrong? Everything was,
what are the other guys doing wrong?
Everything.
They don't know what the
fuck they're doing job well,
that 100% they have no fucking clue. What
the fuck did all of them? All of them.
100%. I have people fucking
drinking. They're like, oh,
their drink is see like the drink and uh,
um,
was it a salt water during the fucking,
then the week of the fight and uh,
you know, I hear if gas from
att like, Hey George, why,
why the fuck would they do that?
Because that's fucking, that's Asinine.
Have I have people fucking be like,
oh,
we don't want to cut carbs
out because we want, you know,
like it takes a specific amount of time
to rehydrate carbs. They, you know,
they're thinking it takes
like four fucking days,
but when you actually do it properly,
like this is, this is all scientific shit,
like literally takes
24 hours to rehydrate.
Somebody is fucking glycogen storage
if you fucking take their water right?
So every gram of glycogen hold on
to three grams of water, right?
And we can literally find out based
on the amount of muscle tissue that
individual holds,
exactly how much glycogen your body holds
and how much water that is attached.
That glycogen do you work with
Y'all Ramiro? We did. Yes. That too.
I look at that guy and I go,
how the fuck is a 185 pound man?
You want it?
You want to hear you wanna hear
some stats with us, man. So people,
people were like, ah, you'll
like, I don't have 100% you know,
like great Joe and I take time
making wait. I'll tell you,
I take pride in that shit.
You know why?
Because I've taken motherfuckers that I
know they're not going to make weight.
I know that. You know what I'm
saying? But Dude, I'm like,
hey man, my, you know, I want to either
a be there. It'd be like bitches,
he's not gonna make it. And
I cut that shit. I could.
I've got coaches that are like,
he's being a pussy. I'm like, dude,
he's going to die.
He literally is fucking cut point to
God damn pounds in the last 30 minutes.
He's got 10 pounds ago. He ain't gonna
make it. He's kidneys are going to be, oh,
he's being a pussy. Fuck you. No,
fuck you guys, man. I cut it off.
You know what I'm saying with you?
Well,
just between us, right?
No one's listening.
So I'm in Australia.
He showed up at one 98 and he missed
by two and a half pounds right with us.
He showed up 217 pounds and was 5.2 and
the only reason that he fucking miss by
that point too,
just cause it fucking athletic commission.
The commission in New York, brush them
off. They fucking came in there like,
I was like, Hey, I'm broke. I'm
like, cool down. Take your time.
I'll give him 45 minutes to like fucking
just chill. We put them in the bath.
Then the commission came in there and
we're like, yeah, how are you feeling?
He's like, I feel good to
go. And they were like,
you know the guy you literally
said, he said, you know,
unfortunately that's what all heroes say.
But unfortunately all heroes are dead.
And I'm like,
first off,
that's the dumbest thing I've
ever fucking heard in my life.
Like there's a lot of fucking heroes
that are still fucking God down the line.
You know what I'm saying? He wants
a quote and I'm sitting there like,
what the fuck are you talking about? You
know what I'm saying? But they were like,
he's, you know, he needs to be
downstairs. And I were like,
well he has a whole hour and they were
like, no, no, he needs to be downstairs.
Even when he got down there, he was
still sweating on the fucking scale Joe.
And it was fucking too,
but here's my thing.
He showed up to 17 and we got
him point to over 85 that Mama,
I weigh one 97 and I stand
next to him and I'm like,
how in the fuck is that 185 pound man.
He is a straight up silverback.
That dude is so jack,
you want to talk about genetics?
I mean what kind of fucking
genetics is that dude have
first night we fucking were doing the
co with them. He had never done it.
He never did a bath.
I know he never did a bath because he
went in backwards like literally like
we're like yo head goes over here bro.
Like you'd never been in a bat.
He got out,
he fucking lost a lot more weight than
he expected and he fucking butt ass naked
man. Fuck. Comes into us. Ah,
the fuck. I'm like, oh yo bro.
Fucking not hugging me, like shaking me
and shit. I'm losing my man card tonight.
But you know what? I fucking, I'm
not going to fucking, you know,
he's a big fucking dude.
So
if you know what I'm
saying? Yeah. He's uh,
he's like the freakiest of all
the freak athletes, you know,
of all the dudes where you just
like, you look at them, you go,
what are the odds that someone turns
out like that? You know of all the,
all the guys who like, like a regular
book and guys like an Evan Dunham,
regular looking guy and
then you got to Yo Romero,
it's like the world's not fair.
That's not fucking fair math.
It's not fair. And that's him on
weight, right? I mean, what the fuck?
What Day it is a redemption.
Okay. Yeah. So that is him.
Back in the day when you had a cut
actual weight for the weigh ins.
That's before the,
like if you look at 'em with the new
ones where he gets to rehydrate such a
freak man. Fuck. And when he talks,
tosses getting the fact that he's in
his forties, like what in the fuck?
And they test that shit out of
that dude that they don't even,
that doesn't even make sense.
Like one plus one is 18 test them again.
It doesn't make any sense.
How come you don't work with him anymore?
I do. Oh, you're still doing what?
I'm so yeah, just uh, we had uh,
we were working with,
uh,
Robert Whitaker and they decided
to not use us the last week.
Um, we're like, all right, so we
call it gives you the last week, Bro.
There's a lot of shit.
You know how this game goes.
I do know how this game goes.
This is,
this is one of the more disappointing
aspects of this game is that I feel like
I'm fighting in particular
is so it's so dangerous.
It's so personal.
It's so there's so much involved that I
feel like loyalty should be at a premium
and it should be one of the most
emphasized things like your team,
as long as you have a good team,
like your team is critical.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's everything for the emotional
stability of the fighter,
but also for not feeling like you're
a piece of shit. Right. You know,
and I think there's something to that
these guys had just dumped their trainers
and,
and dumped their coaches and then hop
from camp to camp and don't get a better
result from it. I think there's part
of them that realizes like, hey man,
this guy brought you to the dance and you
abandoned them somewhere along the way
because you know,
you a greener grass
on the other side of the fence and
it didn't turn out to be greener.
And if you don't feel like a champion,
you know,
you'll feel like kind of
a weasel. Right, right.
And there's a lot of guys like that,
but then there's guys who are,
they're in a situation like Tj Dillashaw,
right.
Where he was in a situation where he
was like, this, this doesn't seem right.
Like I don't like the
way this camp has going.
And then Duane Ludwig
comes along and he's like,
I am fucking learning and growing
with this guy. And he's like, look,
I gotta go guys, I'll still
train with you. I love you,
but I got to think about my future.
And then they'll like you fucking weasel.
You left us. But look, he's
right. You look at the results.
Clearly he was right. I mean, Tj right
now, uh, he's, he defended his title,
beat Cody twice, one of the best in
the world. You look at his improvement,
his overall growth is improvement
inside the octagon. Like he was right.
You know, and so it's a,
it's a, it's a weird balance.
Like when do you pull the chute? When
do you bail? When you get out of there?
You know, when, when, uh,
you know, the first person I
ever worked with Brian, Stan,
you know, me and him were in the
Marine Corps together. You know,
like there's still only
reason I'm actually doing
what I'm doing today because
of Brian. Yeah. Oh Wow. I love that
guy, dude. He's that shit in, you know,
I love him to death, man. He's
a, he's just all around him.
I want him to run for president, Bro. I
don't understand. Motherfuckers are like,
you know, I was just analogy. I'm like,
aw, you don't let, people were like, oh,
this guy's a good guy. He's never
cheated on his wife. He never done this,
done that. And I'm like, Dude,
look at the motherfucker.
He doesn't have options saying like,
look at him Brian,
that motherfucker's got
options. He's like, I'm like,
you are so God damn good. Like you
would get a text from a, like a female,
and they'd be like, Hey, I
just did a photo shoot, blah,
blah, blah. And I'm like, no,
my wife would not appreciate you. Uh, you
don't text me in this form of fashion.
And I'm like, I hate
hanging out with you, bro.
You made me feel like a horrible person.
That's another thing. This is always on.
You know what I mean? He's just a good
month. If he's a great guy, he's a great,
great fucking guy. You know what I mean?
But uh, you know, at the end of the day,
man, you know, he uh,
we, we, I'm like, you're,
you're built like a god down t rex,
you know, big head fucking short arms.
You know what I'm saying? And you know,
at WC you fucking won the world title.
Got To, you know, UFC, it wasn't
working out for him. I'm like,
you need to go to one eight five is like,
you know,
you helped me out to cut
the fuck. Yeah, dude, man,
that's what I was doing
in the Marine Corps.
I was helping guys get down to a weight
and then they had to actually perform.
That's what my job in the Marine Corps.
So your job with the Marine Corps was
helping guys get down weight so that the
performance would be better
in combat, right. You, you
have to actually, you have,
you have weight standards and we have
performance standards in the Marine Corps.
So how would you dial
that in based on body fat?
Based on just how much mass
there k the carrying around.
I think there's a lot to it, but
you know, it depends on, you know,
yeah I absolutely like okay this,
this, the build this individual,
this is where activity level,
this is what time they wake up,
but then they go to sleep.
This is what their mos,
which for us that's military
operational skill. Like you know,
if you have something that's a recon
marine and they're going to have a lot
different caloric needs and
somebody that's a fucking
mad man, you don't, right,
right. So, you know, we give the body
what it needs when it needs it. You know.
And it's funny cause we never
have a, a base diet. You know,
like if somebody is basically um,
they don't have an anaerobic workout
throughout the day, you know,
like a ketogenic diet is perfect for them.
You know what I'm saying?
Like they don't need those carbs.
They don't, they don't like it.
Like you actually need a ketogenic diet
because you give the body what it needs
when it needs it. When
your aerobic, you're by his
primary source of fuel is fat,
your body's primary source few ways is
going to be that fat. So what do we do?
We feed it the fucking fat,
you know what I mean?
If you are anaerobic and
your your training throughout
the day, then we, you know,
we actually incorporated
a lot more carbohydrates.
I'm just giving someone who's
lifting weights, doing shit.
What I'm saying, you know, people
nutrition a lot like religion.
If you fucking don't agree with somebody
like lot my friends are like, oh dude,
this guy, I don't know what the fuck
he's talking about. I've noticed that.
It's very bizarre when I've
had some conversations on
the podcast recently about
that, uh, more,
more ways than one was the most civil
one was between Lane Bryant and Dominic
D'Agostino where they were
tall lean Norton rather
where they were talking about
a ketogenic diets versus um,
uh,
carbohydrate diets and a
bio lane. Uh, you know,
do you know Layne Layne Norton?
Yeah. Well, I, I did see
that super, super smart guy.
George is going on that podcast. You'd
better fucking watch this. I'm like, wow,
okay. Yeah, Super Smart Guy.
Very but more emphasizes carbohydrates.
Whereas Dom D'agostino was, uh, they're
both scientists, like legit scientists.
He emphasizes Ketogenic Diet and it's,
it's very,
it's very interesting conversation because
lane really never was on a ketogenic
diet for a long period of time.
Whereas Dom emphasizes that when you
get a fat adapted over longer periods of
time, four to six months,
it, you, your body,
there's some legitimate benefits with
cognitive function and even performance
benefits as, as time goes
on, but certainly is in
terms of your energy level,
your ability to perform was that okay?
Oh,
systemic. No matter what
says 10 my Callso Day, like,
you know, like, guess I'm like Connor, you
know, if I put them on a ketogenic diet,
he'd be fucked. You know what I mean? He's
powering output quick, fast in a hurry.
You know,
your muscles use that glycogen from that,
that part of the muscle, whatever
they're using right there and then,
whereas because he's explosive
100%. Yeah. You know, and that's,
and that's where I think people have a
problem. Like, you know, like I'm not a,
you know, I will say Voltaire,
you know, he says you,
you knew the true knowledge of individual,
not by the, by the uh, answers that you,
but, but by the questions
they ask, you know,
like a lot of people were like
a la carte, you know, like, uh,
there's peanut butter. Good for me. I'm
like, well it depends. I can talk to you.
[inaudible] going to say though,
when this road is too long,
is it the time to travel motherfuckers is,
when is it good for you?
That's the wrong question is when is
it good for you? What are you doing?
What is your activity level
kind of peanut butter, right?
Shit that's piled up with sugar
or real pain on the fuckers.
Did I tell you that people like, it's like
people are like, well, you need healthy.
I'm like,
what the fuck is healthy?
You're putting oil in your gas tank
and putting gas in the oil pan.
You know what I'm saying? Everything that
you do in a restaurant quotion you beg,
you break down your body,
your body's using fuel on a different
ratio based on the iTivity that you have.
And it's like, well, if you're
giving your body carbohydrates,
but your body's using fats,
why the fuck is that healthy?
You know what I'm saying?
It's not, it's not. It's so,
it's so simple. But you know,
we, we started, people follow this program
grow and, and they're like, Holy Shit,
I feel I'm never hungry.
You have energy and this because
you're giving the body what it needs
all the time. All the time,
Bro. Do you limit any foods?
Are there any, like, do you,
do you allow people to eat pasta or bread?
Do you cut anything out of the Diet?
I mean, honestly, they can have whatever
they want at the right fucking time.
You know? Like if you look at like
the metabolic equivalent, right?
For somebody like yourself and say,
you go on the fucking bus,
the fucker workout out,
you can burn 800 calories.
You know you can burn 800 calories
in a workout, no problem, right?
So if you're burned 800 calories in your
anaerobic and your body's primary says
a few,
it was going to be carbohydrates.
Let's just take all the formulas and
all the math out of it for a sec,
but let's say 800 calories.
There's four calories for every one
gram of carbohydrates for you to fucking
replenish what you need.
You need 200 grams of carbohydrates.
Just replenish what you
just did for a workout.
How many mother fuckers do you know
take 200 grams of carbohydrates?
Postworkout none. None. None. Very
few, but, but at the end of the week,
they're like, I don't know why
I'm so tired. You know, like
so what kind of carbohydrates?
We do like say if someone wanted to do
like something like a crossfit workout or
something like that. Kettlebells, Chin
ups, box jumps, Shit like that, right?
What kind of carbohydrates to do you
have them refuel with postworkout fruit.
Dextrose,
caffeine and salt,
all those hundred percent because that's
going to activate all the grains of
salt as a carbohydrate. No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no. You just add it too,
because in terms of transporters,
that is one that is,
it activates the escalate one is
a sodium dependent transporter.
Now how much salt,
how much salt would you add and what
kind of depends on how much weight they
lose. So say if I did a hard
workout a lot, I lose seven pounds.
Fuck man. So what if I kick, you know,
like beat the shit out of the bag. Tea,
fucking run around the block,
do hill sprints and come back
five pounds lighter or whatever.
You just give me a number.
Okay.
Basically with sweat and now this is,
I'm,
I'm negating a lot of fucking
other math. Okay. What?
Every pound is basically
500 milligrams of sodium.
Every pound that you lose for assault,
you lose about 500 milligrams sodium,
she lost pounds.
You would need basically 3,500 milligrams
of sodium to fuck or replenish with.
Fuck you dude. That
seems like a lot. Yeah.
Not Listen to get in a lot of other
fucking things I'm telling you.
But a lot of things like people are like,
that's a lot.
There's a lot of science. Did you
look at this from fucking average Joe?
How many average Joe's gonna lose seven
God damn parent of fucking work. Zero.
Right? Then they're like,
I lost half a pound.
250 250 milligrams and fucking sodium.
You're good to go. You know what I mean?
So how do you have them take the sodium
and what form it's all going to be like.
I actually want them to take a
carbohydrates during and post workout.
Yeah. Fruit. Uh, fruit. Yeah.
So it's going to be blended fruit and
in in the dextrose is going to be a
specific type of sugar.
They drink it.
And what happens is when you increase
insulin, that actually decreases cortisol,
right? Cortisol's not a
fucking bad thing, man.
It's a Google corticoid that actually
helps get rid of inflammation.
Problem is like, people nowadays are
like, ah, it's the fucking stress hormone.
And she'll like, your body doesn't create
a fucking hormone. That's bad for you.
It's not going to like, your bike does
not create something that is bad for you.
It's just bad for you at the wrong
times and in the wrong doses.
Excessive against instance is instantly
bat for you. Fuck me. Ask a diabetic.
They're like, fuck, I wish I had
that shit. You know what I'm saying?
But you have it in excessive amounts.
You know what I'm saying? That's,
that's our problem man. I mean, we just,
we don't know when they're
taking how much to take.
So do you have guys take those glucose
gels like those like runners take or no,
no, no, no. I actually, you know, like,
you know, I find out what guys like to,
you know, at the end of the day, like
consistency on a diet is the
most important fucking thing.
If I get somebody on the zone diet, the
Paleo Diet, the fucking grave who died,
there was 75,000 dots and the fuck home,
you know, on the Internet right now,
today, if I fucking have
you consistent on one day,
you're going to fucking certain results.
Consistency. And I always tell people,
I'm like,
I'd rather you be a hundred a hundred
percent consistent on 10% of my diet,
then 100% consistent on 10% of the
dot. You know what I'm saying? Like,
um,
so at the end of the day,
like I have guys that are laid the
half sugar teeth, like, fuck me alum,
Goddamn, eat some fucking
Twizzlers postworkout your
bike's gonna fucking use it.
Your body is going to use it. You know
what I'm saying? I've heard that before.
Or people that recommend can be a
hundred post workout. Is it the best? No.
You know, like, you know,
I know you have Rhonda Patrick Talk
about ATP trapping and Shit like that.
But you know, like when you're, when
you're done working out, you know,
your body needs those carbohydrates quick,
fast in a hurry.
It's going to activate those,
those transporters and your body's
going to use them. Is it the best?
100%. No, but it's, it's, um,
keeping your sanity and it's consistency.
If somebody works their
ass off and they're like, I
knew if I worked my ass off,
I get some fucking Twizzlers.
Yeah, you're gonna,
you're gonna see a lot better results.
So what, what would you recommend though?
So if someone isn't, doesn't have a
sweet tooth, but you just, they say, hey,
what should I use to replenish my glycogen
Lockhart and least submit line and
would be that? No, no. Honestly like a,
like a fruit toast fruit
though. She's from fruits,
right? Breakdown fruits, right.
Uh, as sugars like a
dextrose is, is, is, it's a,
it's a basic sugar, you know, like,
yeah, it's a monosaccharide. Um,
so you can find that in just about any
kind of fucking sugar. Like cane sugar.
What are you thinking about?
Like chocolate milk.
I know a lot of guys were
doing that and stupidest thing,
that was a big thing for
a while, right? Dude,
this is thing about studies and she liked
it. I mean, I like, it was like this is,
this is the best thing for fucking
post workout. Right? Same. Fuck.
That was from the NSCA NCA come out with
another fucking study was like, well,
you know, like 89% of the fucking and
Latino population is lactose intolerance.
93% of the African American population
is lactose intolerant and fucking,
I was like 90% of the fucking, um, uh,
Asian American populations
like those and died. I'm like,
you guys literally just did a goddamn
study and you show them that most of the
goddamn population is lactose intolerant,
but you're saying that the milk is the
best God damn thing in the fucking game
as it's stupid. It's Asinine,
you know, like, and protein like,
again, easy if, if somebody is
like, if you take, you know,
chocolate milk post work I,
but like, Joe, what do you,
what are you using when you work out?
What do you,
what is your body using when you work
out? Is it using cars? It using protein.
If your body's using
protein as a source of fuel,
you're fucking doing something fucked
up, man. You know what I'm saying? Like,
literally your body go through, you know,
Gluco neogenesis, you know, like fucking,
it'll, it'll, it'll turn protein
and a fucking carbohydrates,
but that ain't the way it's
supposed to fucking be.
So you would never recommend someone
doing like that Carnivore Diet? No,
no, no. See I'm never, I'm a never, never
guy. Like I'm never going to say never.
You know what I'm saying? Because
depending on your lifestyle, you know,
if you were sedentary and, and uh,
you know, you don't do anything,
that's anaerobic. I'm going
to, um, I would promote the,
the ketogenic diet for somebody.
Yeah. It's not even a ketogenic diet.
That's the thing about the carnivore diet.
Patrick went over pretty much in detail
and she thinks what's going on for the
most part where people are seeing
results is basically calorie restriction
because you're not just,
you're just not eating that many calories.
Meaning only stake in terms of like how
much you're using throughout the day.
And a lot of these people
were eating like one,
two meals a day and they're
losing massive amounts of weight.
They're down to the weight they were when
they were 21 and they feel fantastic.
All the gut problems go away.
All the different, you know, uh,
issues they have with auto immune
diseases go away. And she's like,
this is all mimic by calorie
restriction diets. She was like,
this is most likely what
you're experiencing.
And there's a bunch of other nutrition
experts that are sort of examining now
because it's become quite a movement.
This coin award diet,
people are like calories
in, calories out, you know,
like 40% of calories from protein are
actually using the breakdown of protein.
So if I eat a hundred calories of protein,
40 of them motherfuckers are used
to actually break down the protein.
And then there's a thermogenic effect.
It actually heats the body.
Like you eat a lot of fucking money,
you know, it's your body's hot as fuck.
You know what I'm saying? Um, yeah.
That's one of the things they've got it,
that's one of the things they
actually recommend. If you're cold,
like if you get drenched,
if you're, you know,
you to rewarm like there's these things
that they do rewarming drills in the
military and they recommend you eating
and eating is a big part of trying to
heat up because your body
starts generating heat to
try to break down the food
that you're taking in so much
that we look into like, you know,
10% of your metabolism actually
comes from breaking down food.
10% that's a fuck ton of calories,
man. That's all you know.
And that's when we actually
come to rehydration.
Like in terms of the fighters
getting ready for the fight,
we actually take a look at that.
Like,
do you want your body breaking
food down while you were fighting?
And stuff like that, right? You know,
your enteric nervous system and your
body's not going to be like, you know,
we're going to break this food
down. I actually, you know,
like with your entire nervous
system is bodies. You know,
if you see a fucking
bear, but it's like, hmm,
we're going to break down food or we're
going to run from the fucking bear.
You know where to fucking run.
So it sends the Nora half
afternoon through the body,
fucking you stop digesting.
But that doesn't, it doesn't mean that's
just not stealing your fucking gut.
Right. But with that,
with that being said,
like in terms of the main shit like that.
Yeah man,
like a large percentage of that is
actually used to break down foods and it's
like,
uh,
we talk about Glucagon and I get so
many fucking people that are like,
that's not how the body works.
You know? Like I, I get,
that's not how the body fuck whores. When
you, when you fucking hate the protein.
Like it's not like your body's like,
oh,
we're going to shoot glue gone
through the fucking system,
but how many times have you ain't no
fucking high pancake fucking breakfast and
you're like, let's go fucking kick
today's ass. No. You were like, fuck,
let's go back to bed. You have
a big ass omelet. You know,
you're like sucked today's Dick
and let's fucking go kick some ass.
You know what I'm saying? Like you have
energy. If this Glucagon's fucking,
you know, through your system obviously
like it's not the way the body works,
but you know, in in, in
essence like when you're,
when you're taking a specific things
at specific times you're going to,
you're going to promote the usage of,
of, of uh, carbohydrates more or less.
So those pancakes wouldn't
be a bad thing after workout,
after workout a hundred
percent every now what?
You would haven't wrap that up,
so fruits,
but what other kinds of sugars
do you recommend a guard take?
Postworkout hard workout.
We would give them like,
who work with so many guys, like you know,
like they're sponsored by this company,
the second company, but we'll give
him whatever the fuck they want.
They're like in terms of the dextrose
and dextrose is just a monosaccharide is
basically just a simple short,
straight away from it. There you go,
bring it to you. It moves. The arm
goes this way, it goes that way.
Joe, me and technologies do not just
keep it near you, just keep it near you.
That's all you do.
You don't have to lean,
break the moves towards you. That's
what I'm trying to say. Look,
grab the arm reaching,
grab the arm towards you
this way because that way it goes back.
Um, and uh, before a fight.
Yeah. What do you have,
like when like say if Connor is going
to fight it, nine PM's the main event,
when do you have them eat and what is,
what do you have in the,
so we have to break it down
to the amount of meals, right?
So what we do is you basically find
out the amount of muscle tissue that
individual has. So like he's weighing
what on the day of the fight, one 70 ish.
So we have to, it's not necessarily,
you're like, uh, your weight,
but it's your lean muscle tissue. So you
have your lean body mass, right? So if I,
let's say you're 200 pounds,
right? You're 200 pounds.
You didn't say you have 10% body fat.
That means that you're 180% a
180 pounds of lean body mass.
A lot of people were like, oh, that
means I'm 180 pounds of muscle. Now,
that actually means the only 40% of
that is actual lean muscle tissue. Now,
each kilogram of lean muscle tissue
holds onto 13 grams of glycogen.
So we have to find that.
Okay,
how much muscle or how much lean
muscle tissues do you hold? All right.
Now how do you find that out to 40% do
you have them submerge and nor do I have
literally like we've had the,
uh, the hydrostatic testing.
We've done the um, um, the
fuck is that guy, his kindness.
Thank you. Thank you. I
appreciate it. That's what,
that's what you bro Fucking this big
word that scans the one that he used,
the performances that,
I don't think I'm saying that correctly,
but something like that.
$500,000 piece of gear,
right? Fucking there. They're
wrong. 100%, bro. 100%.
I literally, here's the thing,
there's things that, you know,
scientifically can't happen.
Your body cannot be anabolic and
catabolic is same fucking time.
So if you're like, you know, I got some
of, so many people are like, Hey George,
I want to, I want to gain muscle and lose
fat. And I'm like, so do I, man, I fuck.
I would love that, but it's
impossible. It's impossible.
Your body cannot be anabolic and catabolic
at the same fucking time. Right? Well,
we went, we went into that machine
last year with fucking Carter, right?
Showed him and I literally day, I'm
like, that's how good I fucking him.
But it showed him gaining muscle and
losing actual fat. It's impossible.
I'm like those,
those are incorrect.
Those routines possible
over a long period of time.
You're saying obviously some people
do gain muscle and they do lose fat if
someone's on a signage. So if
you get, so here's the thing,
if you gain muscle mass,
your your body fat percentage can go down.
Right? Right, right. So let's
say like, oh, it's like, okay,
I gain five pounds of muscle and I
only gained like a half a pound of fat.
My body fat percentage is going to go
down because your body weight got heavier.
100% but did I lose fat?
No, I did not lose fat.
If you look at it like, okay, your
body has it makes sense. Yeah. I see.
What your possible. How does
one lose body fat? Well,
you gotta be in the catabolic state.
You gotta be at a deficit,
and when you are at a deficit, you're not
going to gain muscle and fat. He said,
yeah,
if anybody says otherwise,
they're full of shit and
they're on an infomercial.
But if you buy today for 1999
the truth brother,
so that's just how the body works.
The body works in that
if you're gaining muscle,
you might have less percentage of fat,
but that is because your body is
getting heavier, right? Right. Yeah.
You can lean out like your body
fat percentage can go down,
but if you look at like a Dexa scan,
it's going to be like, okay, you have,
let's say, yeah, 50 pounds
of fat. It's not going to be
like, it shouldn't be like,
oh, now you have 40 pounds of
fat and more muscle. Right.
100% I see what you're saying.
So you calculate how much lean muscle
mass he has lean muscle tissue,
excuse me. And then you coordinate
his meals accordingly, right? Yeah.
So it's like, okay, well he's
going to fight at this time,
or she's gonna fight at this time.
This is the amount of meals that they're
going to have dictated on the amount of,
you know, like after rehydration,
so on and so forth this month,
this amount of carbohydrates
that they actually have to have.
And it's funny because men and women are
totally different. Right. You know, man,
he used to work with Cyborg.
I don't work with Cyborg.
That was an extreme weight
cut though, right? Yeah. We'll
go with that. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, yeah, she's, yeah, she's, it
was tough. Chris is a, is a, is a,
I mean, it's no fucking sign,
you know, she's a big girl,
you know what I mean? Like,
you know, so she walked around that I,
you know,
I don't remember,
but I think it was like in the 70s she
got all the way down to one 41 time.
We make any fucking sense when they
were making her do that. I was like,
why are you making her do that when you
don't even have a goddamn weight class
for it?
I was like,
are you making her do that to show that
she's close to one 35 cents like there's
a one 45 you could five or
fight at one 45 no, no, no.
One 40 like what? There's no one 40 weight
class. Right, right. It doesn't exist.
Right. It's so weird. That was so weird.
Was there and I would see her like the
videos of her fucking crying and trying
to get her down to that weight. I
was like, that's insane. Yeah, no,
it's a it definitely, hey, you know
like with every weight cut man,
it's fucking tough. You know like, well
Chris, like me and her got, we got close.
I think we got a little bit too close.
You know? That's one thing I learned.
Like I had to keep a, I have to have
a separation. You know what I mean?
Cause like when you're like get
the in a bath like right. You know,
you have to have that. And with
her I was like, man we were,
we were so close as friends. I was like,
fuck dude. Like I see what you're saying.
He can't get hardcore. Yeah,
I do too with women too.
I'm fucking horrible. Debate a
bitch, right? Girls. I'm like,
aw man. Fuck Dude. What are you crying?
We don't really have to do this. Do Lie.
Right, right. Yeah.
Who's the hardest that you've ever had
to lose weight? Fucking Vick. James Guy.
Damn van. Why Bitch? He's six
[inaudible] four or finding out what? 55.
He's a big fellow. He got
to got DM. Sweet teeth. Uh,
George touch. Come on, man. Let me ask
some Oreos like after he makes weight.
Doesn't mean it's more years. We have,
we have, we have a little, you know,
getting over there. All right.
You get to Oreos if you do this.
You walk around that, um, he's
in the 90s, man. Jesus Christ.
How much do you think that
affects his actual performance?
Do you think that hinders him talking
business or I'm talking reality. Reality.
Yeah, of course. Man. It's so, it's a
point of diminishing returns, right?
Like you've got to figure out
when do you hit that point?
Cause you look at guys like Dustin
poray done much better at one 55. Yeah,
it looks better than, I mean I work
with, you know, I'll never forget,
like I worked with Dustin when he first
got into you a sheet and they were like,
it needs to be one 45 in 21 days.
Like, let's fucking do it man.
You don't like him and fucking um,
you know, so many motherfuckers,
you know what I mean? You, you're
absolutely right. You know,
you look at that Calvin Gosh to them,
you know,
people don't realize like the point of a
fight camp is not to make weight at the
point of the fight camp is to increase
your skill, increase your ability.
Like it should be pure design session.
You know what I'm saying?
We're talking about like the big beef,
no big motherfuckers that like, yeah,
you're like, this guy's the
strength and conditioning coach.
You don't know shit about periodization.
Do you work with Calvin? Yeah,
we've worked together a lot and
it's, you know, like now, um,
we don't work so much together.
You know, like when he was,
and that's one of the things like a lot
of guys will work with us when they have
to make weight. There's certain guys
like Frankie Edgar, Edgar's like, dude,
he invests in himself.
He knows that like does he,
I mean he shows up almost on weight,
but he's, it's all about performance.
He knows that, you know what
I mean? Same thing with the,
well he's the guy who fought at one 55
when he really was one 55 I ain't get him
to one 25 problem walks.
He's Day one 25 because
people were talking about
him fighting at one 35 you're
saying you could get them to fight 100%
flyweight on a messiah. But you know,
and then people was like,
well I'm black and I'm like this if was
my first whooping ass at one 45 1155
like when they were talking about
like, Oh, you just get more,
and he was a champion at one 55 I'm like,
why the fuck am I going to try and
cut this guy if he's a champion?
You know what I mean?
Like God cause he wouldn't be the champ
champions now I know like one 2,500 you
think so bro. Have you talked to him
about this? A Little Frankie homocide?
No I haven't. I never asked. I will
never ask him. I will never sit down.
If Frankie was like George Georgia want
to get to one 25 I'm like thank God or
thank goodness.
Right.
But he's never asked me so I'll
never bring you work with Tj.
I have worked with Tj, I dealt, me
and him are good friends and this,
this thing with me, Joe, like
I work with fucking everybody.
So like in terms of politics,
like I'm like I'm dirty little slut.
It goes from one room to the next.
You know what I'm wearing right now and
then go to the next [inaudible] dirty
bastard,
you know and it's fucking horrible.
Did they allow that more so with
you because it's a weight cut thing.
It's not like you're,
you're not teaching,
it's not like you work with Tj and you go,
oh,
I know Tj is tendencies and then
you work with another guy. I'm not,
I'm not training you to
be a specific individual,
you training PR person
to make a specific way.
What I tell people is I'm making
you the best you that I can be.
And in terms of business, I'm like,
don't you want to beat the best of them?
And they're like, fuck yeah.
All right, so it's okay.
So that's why they're okay with it.
That's interesting. That's like,
that's a rare section of the
sport where you can do that 100%,
but you have to like it. I've
had, you know, we have a pretty,
we have an awesome team, you
know what I mean? But, uh,
as one thing I have to tell them because
they get so fucking, uh, you know,
like when you're with a, with a fighter
for a camp, you get super close.
And I'm like, Bro, like it's fine to
get close with them, but it's, it's,
it's okay to root for them.
But we never get to a point where we
route and we talk shit about the other
fucker team because Jazz, Oh, we work
with them and we work with, could be,
you know what I mean? For, for a
long time. You know what I mean?
So who does he work with? No,
I don't know. I have no idea.
And he's had some real struggles.
He's had some tough cuts, man.
He's a tough motherfucker. What
was he doing wrong? Everything.
Everything. You know, and it's funny
because I, I think that it's, uh, there's,
there's like a language barrier
and the thing, but you don't like,
there's also like, um, let's say you're
cutting weight, right? And you're,
you're looking at like, okay,
common sense, if I drink water,
I'm going to fucking be heavier.
Right? So fuck drinking water.
But you don't realize you got your Renin
Angiotensin aldosterone system that's
fucking going to be activated if
you fucking cut back water early.
People don't realize that Shit,
man. You know what I'm saying?
So what they do is eat. Your body tries
to hold onto that water. Everything.
Everything in your body is created
from a stimulus. You know what I mean?
Like first email that says
your hot right when you're hot,
what is your body dude?
It's fucking sweat. And then
what happens? Well, Oh shit.
Like my body's dehydrated.
Blood pressure started dropping
and he starts releasing a Adh.
She starts releasing, uh, um,
you know, uh, aldosterone,
shit like that in fucking, you
mention from sweating, you know,
so then I'll look at that. But they
look at it, he's like, I drink water,
puts weight on.
We're going to start drinking water early.
How long have you been working with
Konner? Um, since the Josie Aldo, who's a,
that was the first time I
worked with Josie Aldo for some,
it's been quite a long time. Yeah. Yeah.
How much of a difference has it made,
John?
And it's huge because until then
I was winging it. You know, it,
that the way quitting parts of the
sport is cloaks and daggers and you're
trying, you're overhearing conversations
and you're googling. So, you know, I was,
it was,
was
pretty much guesswork on,
on, on, on my end. You know,
I got him to one 45,
um,
nearly 20 times on my own, but
when we brought George and, uh,
and it wasn't even just
about making weight,
what I noticed with him was
that every session was um,
productive.
There was no sessions where it was,
he didn't have to pop in the
shots or soreness or you know,
that that would just be a normal part.
Whereas when we brought in
George and that, that was a lot,
each session was a lot more effective.
So it wasn't just about making the way
it was making the training camp and where
he was improving the Holloway truest.
He got down to one 45 a couple times.
He looked like, like a monster. You look
like a Zombie. It was terrifying. Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean that how to play a big part in
your decision to no longer have him fight
it that way. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
we'd already gone with the wind.
55 is his final flight before going to
the UFC was was at one 55 and I was kind
of like, oh thank God, you know, this
is just to see what in the better,
because when he joined he was a
sort of a scrawny 16, 17 year old.
But when he started becoming a man,
so getting down there,
it was getting scarier and scarier.
And then his last fight outside of UFC,
I thought you looked fantastic.
It was a handy way coat. Um,
and he just looked at it,
looked like a tank.
Now the offer came in a
couple of weeks later,
Sean emailed me and said
that we're offering you at
one 45 fight in a, in April.
And of course I tell Connor and
he's screaming and running around.
We didn't care what weight class. If he
had to say, well in 25 we would have,
we would have done it.
John specifically want as as a one 45.
And we sort of went, we
went back to, you know,
back to that lighter weight class
and it was almost accidental.
And then soon as we got the opportunity,
you went back up again and he
looked very thick at the weigh ins.
He looks heavier, he looks bigger. Yeah.
And it, you know that that's a part of a,
you know,
the lifecycle of an athlete.
If you're with the same guy for over
a decade, you're going to see changes.
You know, he's Turkey
now, he's not 18 anymore.
It's it there these different things going
on in his life. So if, you know, it's,
that's the benefit I think of working
with someone for a long period of time
rather than, you know, kind
of Jim hopping that you,
you'll know what they can and can't do.
And he does a lot of
unconventional training. Right.
In terms of like physical conditioning,
like I know he,
is he still doing all that stuff with
Ido Portal? Yeah. Anytime. Ito's in, in,
in Europe.
Ped tends to drop in Ireland.
We have a great relationship with them
and he'll play around with that. I,
you know,
the reality is he's,
most of our time is going to be
spent on the fundamentals of MMA.
And the great thing with Ito is he's,
he, especially in training camp,
he will come in and near the end
where you're just tired of doing,
seem to like defense. You're tired
of doing pad work and he comes in,
he does all these fun games. So
we're still working out. We're still,
he's firing his brain in different ways.
He's where he's working in coordination
and balance for me is the, you know,
the head trainer. It's like, it's
a nice break, you know, is a, um,
I'm sure it was John, John
Wayne her and say to, you know,
when you have a fight coming up, you
know how many miles you're going to run.
You know, how many kicks you're
going to trow every now and again.
Do you want to come in and want to do
so long back, uh, jumping in the air,
spinning Albert's itself, it breaks
the monotony and MMA is fantastic,
you know, cause it's all the
martial arts together. It's,
you're almost never going to get forward
because you can always do something
different,
but it's still,
there's still a repetitiveness to it
that it's nice to break with something
unusual. Now, how much does
training change when you're
dealing with a specialist,
like a guy like could be who is
just, uh, uh, grappling phenom?
How much do you shift the emphasis
of the training to take down defense,
working on grappling and do you work
mostly take down defense or do you just
work overall wrestling? So the take down
defense becomes a part of that as well.
Um, all of that, all that. Um, but yeah,
definitely I would maybe talk about later,
like I,
if there's one thing I could change is
that I think I was too defensive in my
mindset for this training camp. But, uh,
Habib has very specific types of
take downs depending on where he is,
whether it's shooting on the
low single London in the middle.
And then on the fence. I, I, you know,
long before Congress do to fight them.
I loved watching him. Um, that's
kind of my areas. The fence.
I just love you right from the Randy
couture days, how to use the fence and,
and peep does it too, you
know, a new level, um, you
know, wanting to take downs.
He hidden Connor. You hadn't actually
done it until the eloquent defy.
So it's nice that we kind of got to
see that at the high crotch. I was,
I'd say a bit of DC and that the high
crotch and then trip on the far leg.
And I think he blocked the wounds, but
he did catch him with it. So, you know,
it was very specific.
Takedowns um,
definitely for this training camp
was the most specific that we went.
And then I remember about a
week out or whenever it was,
he did an interview and he said, well,
if he doesn't make it a fight, Tony,
I don't care who it is.
And I was going to damn it.
I hadn't even looked at
Tony's fights in so long.
So me and the other coaches
like start like, okay, what
does he do again? Oh yeah.
He has that style. And because
we work so specific for this one,
um, Tony could possibly be a fight
in the future. When you, when you,
when you think about the future now, after
the [inaudible] fight, how, what do you,
what are you thinking? Are you
thinking about, uh, just to rest,
let the dust settle and then look at
the landscape? Like what, how did,
how did you approach it?
I might put, he doesn't,
what is he screaming and shouting
for the rematch within minutes?
It's hard to push for that rematch
though, after that fight. Right? Sure. No,
I understand the logic of that. You
know, Tony's kind of errands and stuff,
but I also understand
this is a business and
it will be a huge fight. You know, the
rematch would be a huge fight. Does it,
don't you think that it would be difficult
to sell because of how dominant could
be, wasn't that fight? I'm sure. Uh,
I do think the ground Trey showed
promise. Um, I, I, like I said,
I would like to have change
things up a little bit.
Specifically a more offensive
mindset. I've taught
defensively, we did quite well.
Um, but offensively we weren't
really where we usually are and,
and you know, right when the fight was
over, I was thinking, you know what,
I was kind of going into this like
not to lose, not to win, you know,
and his shots warden as
crisp as they normally are,
he had opportunities to hit him,
especially into turned round.
And he just seemed to be the range of
something was off and that he had to do
with the fact that he hadn't fought at
my main two years. Absolutely. You know,
I'd say right. Yeah, of course. Of course.
And we tried to mimic as
close as we could in the gym.
And I brought in guys that he didn't
know and I would say, this is fight day,
and he didn't you,
you know,
he would do with George exactly what
going to do on fight day and we'd have a
referee and so to, to, to get the fight
feel, but it's still in the gym, which,
you know,
is he at a position now where every fight
has to be a gigantic super fight in?
Is that nes, is that a problem in that,
you know what, I thought after the fight,
after it was all over, I was like,
you know what a good fight would be,
would be him versus Pettis.
Like that would be a really good fight
and it would be a really interesting
fight in terms of stylistic matchup
and it would be a great fight,
I think for Connor to sort of just get
a wild three round or I guess it would
probably be the main event.
It would be five rounds,
but oh well it would be a wild fight.
They would probably favor him. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, the boxing have, you
know, in Tyson fury was kind
of coming back together.
Um, you know, not the toughest guy
in the world. It doesn't happen.
It never doesn't happen to them.
It may specifically specifically to USC,
and there's an issue with that
I think. Yeah. You know, he was,
you know,
at an early stage it was fighting
all the time and as it as natural,
as you get older and as you achieve more,
it is going to start becoming, you know,
once or twice a year. Right. That's just
a natural progression of an athlete.
I don't care who you are,
but the wild fights that he
could have at 155 pounds,
whether it's James Vick or just engage g
or pedis or there's good fights for him
that aren't necessarily could be,
they aren't necessarily Tony Ferguson,
but they're a good fight
to get that timing back,
get everything locked in,
you know,
100% but you have to
factor in his personality.
And he's only fighting now for flights
that are really interesting to him.
He's not that interest in anybody. Not
that I've heard in May where the paper,
Oh yeah, yeah. Money, money,
money, money. Right. So,
you know. Yeah. What more can
he, you know, even with his
spending, well, can I play,
would be the, the eye on the future and
on the eye, on the rematch, you know,
like getting everything dialed in so
that when he does have a rematch with
Khabib, he is Samurai
sword sharp. Yes sir. Yeah.
As opposed to having two years off,
one,
one boxing fight in between them and
then such a grappling heavy contest.
Yeah. I don't disagree. That would be a
trainer. You know, for me as a trainer,
that would be the ideal, but it'll
be hard to motivate him for that.
I think it would be hard to motivate
them and it's, it's not the, you know,
it's not really the AOC model. It's
was obvious it was going to be though.
You know what I mean?
It was going to be those things.
Anybody could tell the UFC what time
it is. It's Conor could be a time,
I mean, if anybody is the guy that
can say, hey, this is what I want,
I want a fucking tune up fight. I wanna
I want a tough guy. He absolutely could.
Yeah. And he absolutely wouldn't,
you know, who is like when, when,
when he lost the Diaz one
fight and a backstage,
he was screaming and shouting.
I at all the tough process of it getting
the rematch at one 70 as quick as
possible. I'm on, I'm in the
background going, please don't,
did you not see that
fight? He's a terrifying, a
individual that's got a one 55,
five and then, okay,
maybe you meet him again.
But he was not letting that go.
And then four months later he fought the,
the exact same guy where that's
where he is right now with could be.
That's all I, that's all I'm
hearing from these. Well listen,
you could sell it for sure.
Especially with the fucking
chaos after the fight. You know,
just keep dealing Dannis at
home. Yeah. He's grounded.
Yeah. So with what would
you do differently? Um,
like I said from it from a strategy point
of view and my number one thing would
be to be more to think more offensively
that we definitely had opportunities to
learn shots on when Connor
land shot, you know, you know,
watch the Eddie fight back again. It's,
it doesn't take them a whole lot of shots.
He rarely misses, you know, even if, if
you look at strikes that it didn't land,
those strikes were for a reason. They
were to see what way he holds his hand.
See where your meals,
like you know,
I used to love watching Anderson silver
back in the day and I thought they were,
you know,
they have a similar kind of approach.
But this one we just didn't
seem to be landing in my,
only when I look back
at the training camp,
we did spend most of her time
with a defensive mindset and,
and I think that's a mistake,
but don't you think that a big part
of it also was that he had to be tired
because could be be so such a Mauler a
hundred percent I mean handle to have
some sort of an effect on his ability
to land those shots. Yeah, yeah.
I'm sure that did. And that was part of
the strategy for one and two, you know,
if we did end up in our backs was not
to put a massive amount of effort into
getting up, just play guard and,
and stay safe because you know,
the next round starts on the feet
and tried to do damage there,
but it's still tiring.
You know, I, I, you know,
kind of gets a hard time about as a
vet is cardio all the time, but who is,
could be faced that didn't look like
that after two rounds and Quinta I quit.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I was super
impressed with ally Quinta in that fight.
It especially considering he came
into that fight looking for a third,
a three round fight. I mean that
was what he was trained for, right?
He was trained for a three round fight
and it changes up and all of a sudden
he's in a five round fight for
the title. Fucking crazy. Yeah.
Crazy set of circumstances.
But it almost makes you wonder,
and this is B, you could speak to
this better than anybody. How much,
how much is much and
in regard to training
for a fight like this,
like maybe training for a three round
fight is the way to go when you have to
fight a five round fight so
you're not so fucking beat up.
By the time you get to the fight, if you
already know how to fight five rounds,
you've already done it.
And if you're a guy like Conor was just
got so much experience in the game,
it might be that it's like there's a
point of diminishing returns in terms of
your strength and conditioning and that
guys just go too far pushed too hard and
just don't have it when it comes to,
I mean how many times have you seen a
fighter be overtrained when they fight?
Very often. Definitely. You know, they've,
they've given their best rounds and the
gym and it's very difficult as well in
those last two weeks because
anxiety is starting to grow.
So you want to train harder,
you'd want to get one more aspiring and
you want to know because the flights
coming in. So it's almost like
when you were back in school,
then you were cramming for an exam.
The exam's tomorrow I'm going to
stay up all night studying. You know,
it actually got me through college,
so that works so much. But,
but in fighting we got to do, we've got
to do the opposite. We don't have it.
We've got to have a
solid taper off period.
And that is hard when you're dealing
with a 20 something year old man and he's
dealing with what's, what's coming around
the corner. So, but you know, that's,
that's the trainer's job. You know, how
much did he taper off for this fight? Uh,
same as usual.
We have about a two week taper off period
where we start bringing it down. Um,
he did that. He did actually spar
even after that. Um, you know, we're,
we're all working very hard for
this fight in the limit, you know,
somewhat limited period
of time. Um, so we did,
didn't taper off quite the
way we would normally do,
but roughly two weeks if
you want to do a rematch.
And if the UFC did grant a didn't,
this is obviously dependent upon how
the Nevada state athletic commission
handles the legal ramifications of him
jumping out of the cage, attacking Dylan,
Dan as the subsequent brawl.
The chaos that ensued.
You mean you're, you're dealing with
a lot of legal shit, his fight that,
that could hold things up. I mean, they
held both guys person is correct. Uh,
well he held a Habib's kind of got
his, yeah. Okay. Kind of got his purse
so he gets his first and Colby.
But I mean,
who the fuck knows what's going to
happen with him, you know, and uh, yeah.
I hope they're, they're lenient on him
and I'm not just so we can get a rematch.
I mean, I love watching
invite first. Um, and I can,
I can stretch myself to understand his
reaction. I can stretch myself to under,
I can't stretch myself to understand the
order guys' reactions on what they did
for him. He jumped over the
cage and he jumps on. It's,
it's not the end of the horse.
The guy that jumped in there was
wearing red who punched on her? Yeah.
I'm not sure. I think that's a spokesman
coach, but I'm guessing he's a fighter.
He fights with the UFC, uh, in
the red. He was an older man.
He actually worked with them. Oh, okay.
You work with, there you go. Who is he?
I don't know his name.
Either. Islam or fun.
Yeah, it was either his Llama.
Yeah. I don't think it was
either. One of those guys,
like I know he is laughing guy. He was,
you know, he hit the guy in the suit.
That heritage is Russian manager.
He hit Dylan. Either way. Um,
there's actually indicates
when your mind is going in and,
and hit him from behind that. Yeah. You
know, I kinda, I kinda understand that.
Like I said, for, for, for Habib, I
didn't think it was, you know, it was,
it's just such a foolish thing to do
because we're listening to date already.
One, I know that Dylan was
talking shit and he was angry,
but she didn't say anything because
I heard a few people signed up.
Now I was standing beside Dylan. I
didn't see what he did, but I could hear.
So he didn't say anything
now and I watched it back.
I seen he kind of beckoned
them on. Yeah. You know,
just stupid end the fight stuff.
But it,
I didn't think it justified
that level of response.
And maybe there was something
else in the lead up. You know,
probably dealing is a
bit of a troll online.
So there's probably a bit of a
build up of voter stuff. But um,
yeah, like I said it, it wasn't that big
a deal to me. What I'd be dead. Yeah.
It just really wasn't. Well,
there's two ways of looking at it.
Well, in terms of like the trash
talking and one way is that man,
does that sell a fight? I mean
it sells a fight. Me Connors,
one of the best ever at, if not the best
ever at it, talking shit to opponents,
getting them riled up and me,
it is the reason why Josie,
although lost his composure and
came charging faith first at Conner.
I mean you got to think emotions
play a big part of that.
It ramps up your stress.
It ramps up the fighters,
a anxiety anticipation and the ramps up,
the pressure on them to win and to,
and this emotion that they're
fighting with fucks up their judgment.
It just does. And it's a major tool
that tonally, that Connor uses. And,
but on the other hand people say,
well I'd like when fighters are respectful
and this is one of the things that
could be saying this, this, this,
uh, supports should be about respect.
You shouldn't be talking about someone's
family shouldn't be talking about
someone's religion. You shouldn't
be talking about someone's country.
But you know,
on the other hand,
that's one of the reasons why Conor is so
fucking huge. It's not just as results,
it's all the other things that come
along with it is the excitement that he
generates a shit talking though. Who the
fuck is that guy? Like that kind of shit.
That's a big part of who he is. It's a
part of who he is as this cultural icon.
I mean it's one of the
reasons why people love them.
I mean they don't just love
his ability inside the octagon,
which is quite substantial
that they love the swagger.
They love when he comes in with rubber
arms and, and struts around the cage.
They love all that shit.
But it's like when is too far?
And that is the question. When is
too far. Yeah. Um, yeah. You know,
Connor is a real ad divider.
You know,
some people will love it and
some people will hate it.
I'm not really that interested
in people's opinions on things.
I'm just interested in what is
and what is that sells fights.
Yeah. There's a reason he's the highest
paid guy. Um, so if that is what is,
and that's just natural for him to do as
well. It's not an act. It's not, you know,
when he's sparring,
like I am an art and were best of
friends and every single sparity Shitoki
Jeweler, oh, you're the
shit today. You know,
you know what I'm formed today
and they're gonna. You know,
people listen to them like they hate each
other and then speak smiles at the end
of it. It's just part of the game
for him. It's partly, he enjoys it.
It's a bit of fun. This one was
darker, you know, as, as, as Dana said,
it definitely was,
but it's just part of who he is.
I don't really involve myself in it.
I tried to stay outside of that and then
just focus on the, the task in hand.
Ever get cringey for you because
you are a very respectful guy. Yeah.
I mean it's absolutely not my personality.
It's absolutely not my personality.
But again, I don't find my own
opinions on things. Very interesting.
I'm only interested in,
um, what is, you know,
there's the fact that he does this
and it's got an the results he has.
Okay. Well I guess that's what he
does. It's not how I am. Right. I mean,
you look at the two biggest
names in combat sports,
Floyd Mayweather and Conor McGregor and
they both do it. Yeah. I mean, you know,
like my favorite fighter back
in the day was fate or, and it,
there was a non that barely said anything
and the is if you want to say love
them. But he was also fighting
mostly in Japan. It's different vibe.
It's a different culture than here.
Um, you know, you could beat that guy.
And I almost have the two extremes.
I've got to Nelson who you never hear
a blip out of. And then I have Connor,
who's, you know, the other end
of the scale. And, um, you know,
you can only be true to yourself, but
at, I look at their, their, you know,
their followings and their sponsorship
deals and their fight purses and stuff.
And it's obvious which one is doing
better. You know, if, if the, if the,
if we can agree on the object, the prize
fighting is to make money and that's it.
The object of martial arts
I think is very different,
but the object of prize fighting
and don't ever lose sight of that.
As soon as I hear a fighter
saying is for some other reason,
I'll try to make them retire as quick
as possible because not being smart,
you know, you're, you're taking
damage for money and keep,
keep that in mind no matter
what your choices are.
Do you have guys in the gym that you see
that sort of mimic Connor? Oh, of course.
Of course. You're talking, you're, you're
dealing with teenagers and, and, and 20s.
And that's, you know, I look back on
myself. It's a hugely impressionable,
impressionable period of your life.
You're always, you're looking, you know,
we young men almost try out
different personalities,
you know, and he was such a strong
personality in the gym. Definitely I can,
I can spot the 18 year old walking in
with a man bone and the Sioux telling me
he's going to be the next year. I probably
wouldn't be the same idea. You know,
it's, it's not different.
But I true again,
months and years of conversations,
you know, not telling them what to do,
but conversations, I sort of say this
is a completely natural thing to do,
but start to find your own voice and find
your own way and if that's who you are,
you enjoy that side but run with it.
If it's not who you were.
Even the fans will see true
very quick as well. You know,
the fans can see when someone is
genuinely doing something and uh,
and doing it as, as, as an act. Now,
who did you guys bring in for wrestling
for this camp? Um, you know, surgery, his,
his wrestling coach since day one. Um,
yeah, we, we, we're not big into like,
Oh, if we bring this guy in under six
weeks ago, we're going to learn, you know,
it's not the approach that the approach
to learn for a camp, but like say now,
like say if you, you got like
w here we are, it's October.
If they say we're looking at July of
2019 substantial amount of time from now,
plenty of time to train and all sorts of
gigantic card the 4th of July weekend.
Right. Well let's, uh, let's,
let's target a rematch for them.
What would you do differently?
Well, who'd you bring in,
in terms of like wrestling? Um,
so when you're, when you're,
when you're dealing with
somebody for this long,
you also know there's personalities.
You know,
and it's one of the reasons why
George worked so well. He's,
he kind of fit it into the,
how the team's structured.
So you might bring in someone who's,
and I get so many great offers
from guys with, you know,
really good credentials,
but what is the use of that if him
and Connor going to clash, right?
No matter which athletes I'm dealing with.
So actually to me,
even almost more important
than anything is, is,
is that they can connect
and that they have a, um, a,
a good working relationship. Now, let
me, let me state very clearly as well.
Surgery is a fantastic wrestling coach.
He's, it comes from agenda, you know,
generations arresting and Moldova.
He's got the real slick,
kind of Russian style of wrestling.
You know,
it's not just about kind of power
doubles. He's very, very slick.
And we have some very, very slick
wrestlers in the, in the gym.
So I think we're good there.
And both guys coming in the past and true.
And we had Helen, Helen morale is
there to female Olympic gold medal, is,
thinks she was the first American
female to get a gold medal.
She did a lesson Macondo and it was
worked out brilliant. So things are,
they think that would happen naturally
like that. I have a busy Jim.
I'm always getting photos coming true.
We're always stealing techniques.
When I tell my guys to
be technique vampires,
get what you can out of everybody
that comes true. You know,
you're never going to have a mindset of,
I don't need to learn from that
guy that like, I don't know,
something that you don't know. Right.
Um, so that, but for a structured,
okay, let's train with this guy
for three months I'm are gone.
That's not really have skilled is,
is passed on us as far as I can
tell from my experience of it.
It's got to work personality
wise and I like a I what,
what,
is there some secret technique that I
remember watching that an interview with
Dan Henderson and he was saying when
he started doing Jujitsu tournaments,
he found it so strange that he wouldn't
warm up or each other or that they were
afraid to see his deep half guard move.
Because in wrestling is,
I know what you're gonna do.
You know what I'm gonna do is it's going
to come down to who can hit it on the
day and he would actually warm up.
But with guys who was going to be
competing with and sometimes even cause it
made the match a little bit better,
they had a bit of a vibe going.
And I don't think there's like big
secret move that Connor could learn that
would suddenly reverse on Habib.
I thought we did quite well.
He almost took him down at the third,
you know, we were ready for that,
that low single and he,
we had a little technique for there and
he actually sat him down for a moment.
He didn't drive in.
We should've ducked you on the hook there
and went into Jujitsu modes and start
passing. But instead he would drew
and could be, did a great job.
He followed them back,
open the angel and then it got to finish.
So I don't think it's necessarily about,
um,
trying to bring in a four time gold
medalist or whatever and make a big
wrestling program that doesn't
quite fit in what we do, you know.
Do you think though that it would help
him to bring in high level wrestlers to
have like intense sparring sessions
within so he could feel that kind of
pressure that could be put on them?
Because the level of grappling
attack I brings to the octagon,
it's very difficult to match. Yeah. Yeah.
It's, it's kind of like on the reverse.
Who would you bring in to bring the level
of striking that Connor can bring in?
You know, it's right. We as trainers,
we're always looking for that, uh, that,
that carbon copy so we can get
as close as we can. And we did,
we had some big one 80,
you know,
when 80 Fiverr's rushing guys who you
were actually begging them not to put
anything online because they
can't go home. But, um, so
we, we had guys that were,
you know,
we're mimicking,
but there's a reason why he'd
be buzz is on the feeling that,
and the world champion. It's, you
can't get another guy like him.
You Mimic as much as possible and
you do drills and you do scenarios.
And you know, Dylan Donald's
was a great training partners,
has over 200 pounds and he actually
comes to wrestling before Jujitsu's got
ready to go take downs.
And he's got a real good eye for
stylistically trying to match somebody.
So you get as close as you can kind
of ever be the exact guy, you know,
so you feel like there's enough room for
improvement that if you could go back
to the drawing board and
give yourself a few months,
that you could get him to a point
where we can have more success the day.
I don't think that will,
I would quit, you know?
So I'm completely biased and I absolutely
think that if we could get another
shot at it, and we kinda thinks
that as well. Absolutely. What did,
what did Conor think after the fight
was over? Like what did he say? Um,
crystal up now it's very down.
He said, you know, watching by,
he hates, he hates Ms. Yates
technical mistake. So that
right hand, you know, that,
that he was very disappointed.
He got caught with a shot like that.
But it's actually funny, I
was just thinking about this,
you know, that right hand,
if you showed it to a boxing coach,
he said, that's horrible. You know,
your head's down,
you're swimming again.
I don't really care about people's
opinions and things I care about.
It's effectiveness that was down
in effective techniques. You know,
it's one of the hardest clean shots comes
being caught with in his MMA career.
Nevermind. And put a boxing guy, you know,
you bring in a box and coach for Habib.
He would train that out of them. No, your
hands here, it goes straight comes back.
So you've got to be careful about
the individual arts. You know,
you wouldn't know it. High Level Olympic
boxing coach wouldn't teach a Beta,
but it's very effective. Dan
Henderson's career. It was,
it was around that technique.
Things changed though when you add in
takedowns right? I mean it's one of the,
doesn't have to worry or did
that, you know, it's a great,
it's a part of being a such a high level
graph or you can go in and swing crazy,
you know, kind of has to go in and be
always worried about the guy coming on.
Anita is underneath the shots.
So yeah, things change styles.
It's what makes the sport so interesting.
Yeah.
We made the comparison between Kevin
Randleman when he fought Mirko Cro cop.
That cro cop was so worried
about the takedown random
and comes to the big punch,
knocks him out.
There was a similar set of circumstances,
kind of recovered very, very quickly.
But yeah, he's had a hell of a chin.
Yes he does. Yeah. He's, he's rarely,
he's rarely hit and that's of course
kept his chin strong because it does
diminish, you know, he's,
he's 15 years spiring almost daily,
you know.
So if he didn't have that style of,
of being elusive,
if he was a war Jim War guy,
he wouldn't be able to do what he's able
to do something hard. Does he spar? Um,
it will. It's a little bit dependent
on, on, on who were against.
If I brought in a sparring partner,
it's like a fight. You know, it,
it's going to be like a fight
he's looking to finish. Um,
if it's a training partner, teammates,
we're probably doing it at a,
at a lower level.
And if you bring in someone,
there's no fucking way they're ready.
They've got to be right.
And I tell them real, I will say
it to them. I say two things.
One he's going to talk to you, don't
take it personal. This is how he lives.
And two, it's going to be a fight.
So protect yourself, be ready.
Now I referee and I'll be quick to
step in. But we have to do this.
We have to get a level of training
that's going to match the intensity of a
contest. Um, ego and did it all
the time. No, you know, that's,
that's only in at a certain period of,
of of the training camp and it's only
going to be for us, it's once every four,
once every eight days is kind of depending
on how to spar went and had a buddy
is the more of that we can do it the
better because it's more directly
correlates to what we're actually
going to do. But then it,
then you've got to be matched against,
well, if he was the GM war type guy,
I'd have to pull back aspiring because
he's taking too many shots. Right?
Could cocoa training camp propane hit?
You know, he's just, he's so elusive,
indicates so good at judging
range and, and so on. So for him,
he can spare all the
time. You know, it's like,
I think another example that
may be Darren till he's,
he's the top dog in the gym,
so he can spare all day long because
he's never re excepts in damage.
But if you're number 10 in the gym,
you probably shouldn't swear
all the time because you're,
you're taking the shot for him
particularly, he loves fighting.
He loves barring after his
favorite part of the training.
You do that seven days a week
of let them, um, you know,
we trains together or areas,
but there's always the glint in the
eye and it's what's today sparing. Oh,
here we go.
How can you decide to do it?
Do you have a set schedule or
do you yeah. Yeah. So, um, we,
we, we, we do things in cycles
and it will vary up for him,
but it's roughly on an eight, an eight
day cycle that I do with him. And, uh,
they want and for we'll be,
we'll be sparing again,
a little bit dependent on where the way
it is and how the last went and how he's
feeling. But if I can get that out
and that's, that's what I did for now.
When you train for the Mayweather
fight, what, first of all,
how much time did you have to prepare
for that? For 10 weeks to the day?
That doesn't seem like a lot. No,
no. I remember just getting the,
getting the message. Do you think that
that was a calculated on Floyd's part? Uh,
maybe he's a very smart guy because it
seems like most of his fights or planned
way in advance,
but that one was like what a couple of
months away just sort of happened. Yeah.
Yeah, it was, was it August? Is that
when the fight took place? It was August.
And so I remember hearing about it and
thinking of like, wait, wait, August.
That's fucking really close.
Right? Like for a Mayweather fight,
you would think six weeks or six
months or something along those lines.
But I would feel like for Floyd is as
great as he is and probably the best ever
in terms of boxing technique
and not being hit. I mean,
he's so elusive still really wouldn't
want a guy like Conor preparing for a long
period of time. It really getting
acclimated. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
it was kind of funny how that all came
about because when he fought Eddie in
November, the year before, I remember
shortly after that we were at a function.
Then I kind of pulled him aside and
I shook his hand and said, right,
you're doing all the best,
enjoy the rest of your life.
And he was kind of shocked it was
saying this to him, but I said,
what else are you going to do?
You're at a two way champion. You've,
you've got out the other
end of this grind, this,
this meat grinder with no damage.
You,
you're in a very small percentage and
you've, you've made plenty of money,
often enjoy yourself.
And um,
and then telling my past couple of
months had passed and then this,
the Mayweather fight,
start talking. And I could,
I could understand that because now his
grandkids were going to be financially
secure. So it made sense
because it was a big pay day.
It didn't really make sense for,
and you got a reason he enjoyed it.
The competition side of it,
that's the matter what you're doing.
Mechanic is going to be competition. I
don't care what it is. He's going to look,
how quick did you do that? You're
like, oh, it's been for pis. Yeah,
I'll do a quicker. Yeah.
He's just that way,
so it didn't start having a bit of a
back and forth. He's like, yeah, okay,
let's put the boxing and be the best
boxer in the world. And for me, my second,
you know, I was on the outside go,
okay, I understand what you know,
does that makes sense to do and nothing
else was really making sense at the time.
It's going to be damaging.
Boxing is a horrendous for to prepare
for and to compete in because we're just
looking at one thing, really punches
to the head, you know? I don't know.
Of course the buddy's house as well,
but, but it, it's, it's so damaging.
The only justification I can
see for that was, you know,
your grandkids are financially
set. Yeah. Tremendous.
Tremendous hype behind a tremendous amount
of money. Did you think he could win?
I of course I'm, I'm, I'm always gone
to think that way. You know that,
that's my mindset. Let's prepare
as best we can. That's the,
it's their options here. Um, when he
landed that uppercut and the first round,
what did you think? Yeah. Like even
when he went down to do that. So,
you know we did a whole training camp
and we brought in, you probably heard,
we probably haven't thought
about that to my knowledge.
And that was my first time
ever seen him against the uh,
recognize boxer cause in the gym we
have a local guys in those sparring
sessions.
Cause what we got to see,
the clip that was released was
Connor lighting moule analogy up.
But Paulie Malignaggi insists that most
of the sparring was him dominating.
Now that's not what I saw. Um, you know
when we, when he came back from it,
like he did it a spar, he
went away, it all broke. Cause
know a picture got leaked.
And then he probably did
a little of interviews.
He was on the east coast work in the
show. So when he came back, he came back,
it was coming back to have
a fight and it was actually,
it was a weird night in the gym because,
uh, the, the Fertitta brothers come in,
Dana commander was a few celebrities come
in. It was a fight, you know, and, and,
and the,
the referee was there.
Joe Cretae is a great guy and he
did 12 hard rounds. And I do it,
I think there is something being released
on Netflix soon at documentary based
around our fight and it will have all the,
have all the rounds. So I guess really,
yeah, I mean we have, of course we have
the rounds, we have to 12 rounds and a,
it's, as far as I'm aware, I just actually
did an interview for a recently there.
I think it's a tree park
documentary that's going to
be on Netflix soon. And uh,
so people will get to make
up their own minds about it.
But just going back to the fight. So what
did you think though about the sparring
when he walked out? When they walked
out first and I went to myself,
I have no idea what's going to happen.
I seen unboxing amateurs back
home and some pros, I, I'm,
I'm horrendously ignorant
of the boxing world. I just,
I just don't really follow it. And he
was schooling those guys and I was like,
yeah, but they're in a world
champion at that elite level.
So that night when he went into the
ring of Paul, I was like, you know,
me and Owen are kind of like,
what's going to happen here? Is He,
is he just going to get tooled? And then
we have to scratch our heads and go,
shit, well we're, we going to do here.
But he came back after the rounds and me
and him are going, wait, wait a second.
It's not magic. It's still punching in
its range and there's techniques. And
so I got, my confidence was
growing, my confidence was
growing, so I knew I, I knew,
no matter what happened, it was going to
be a good fight. It wasn't going to be,
you know, you could win and
just this looks terrible.
He's is missing whatever you shard and
he's being made look silly. Who Was it?
A good fight, you know, it's entertaining.
I think no one in the crowd
was saying that was ridiculous.
No one was saying that was
a waste of money. It was,
it was an entertaining fight and it's
going to be one of those things that I'll
be an older man than I am now and
I'll be talking about at the time we,
we went into the boxing
world and fall flight,
even though the night I was kind
of just looking at it, scratch me,
what am I doing here that's valued,
may it and his dad over there.
These are guys that,
you know,
of all the boxes I always preferred
watch in Floyd and anyone else because I
love defense.
Defense to me is the most intriguing
part and him and Tony and uh, those,
those type of guys and how we work the
Philly shell. And it was, it's beautiful.
It's so interesting to watch
and you getting on a bit, um,
but still able to compete so fantastic.
Is this whole career,
it was defensive base. Never took the
shots. Never, never was damaged into gym.
There was damage in fights,
but yeah,
when he was in the ring and divert
working in the corner in air corner,
I'm just going, what the hell is
Connor doing? Fighting Flight?
This is just strange. Even even
at the beginning, you know,
and so he used to Bruce buffer and it
was a different guy and he hit the bell
three times. I was like, Oh, you
had to do that in the rocky movies.
I remember that thing. Dane,
Dane, ladies and gentleman,
it's kind of the beginning of the
ceremonial and I was like, Oh shit,
that they're actually going to
parks, you know? Right, right,
right until the end of it.
It was still just head scratching and
then fly coming over at the end and given
him a little compliment.
You know,
he's got a hell of a shawl and he's
tough as nails and it was just,
it was a great experience. Oh, I
wouldn't do anything different.
It's the polymeal Nrg sparring session,
which she said was like a fight.
If it was scored as a fight, you think
Connor would have won the fight? Um, yeah,
of course. I'm going to say yes
and then we'll say, well no.
Everybody was there in the night,
had asked Dane eat.
Actually Dana knows a lot
more about boxing the media
than I do and all of those
guys were going, okay, we have a fight
on our hands here. This is going to be,
this is going to be an interesting
contest. So Rhea I buy,
I'm of course going to say,
yeah,
well I guess people will see it
around and make up their own mind.
But it wasn't as one sided.
It's those clips that were
released were forced Polly,
he landed his shots as well.
Of course he's a brilliant boxer
was for me as a trainer was,
it was amazing. Look at him,
you know, he's, he's like,
he's put on a little bit of weight and
you still have to go 12 rounds because
after about round four was gone and he's
not going to continue her cause it's
breeding very heavy and he'd been
hit hard and he'd been sat down once.
And whether that was a push or opponent,
you,
you guys can make up your own mind
at that, but a lot of heavy shots.
I'm thinking he's going
to be out here by six.
So we had another sparring partner.
I'm ready. And I was like, okay,
just be ready to go cause I think this
will go by six rounds. And then Paul,
he just hit this rhythm and start learning
his own shots and it turned out to be
a great, a great content. You know,
it's a contest because it wasn't a
spiral they were talking to all time.
Paul was talking to me, he was talking
to the camera man. He talked to him.
He was almost better than Conrad.
It was great to watch.
Everybody had a great night.
And I think the bill actually bizarrely
enjoy it at the lake kind of con or an
aid. It's Batman and the joker, like,
you know, they both need each other each.
It's a weird dynamic when you,
when you see a contest like that.
Well he was campaigning for a fight.
Yeah. He's trying to get Connor to,
to box him.
Yeah.
It's not out of the realms
of possibilities real.
It's absolutely an outer realms
of possibilities. There's,
there's all sorts of crazy
rumors going around the,
the managing team and the fight
team and what might happen next.
It could be boxing group, it could be
him, it could be Floyd, Floyd. Again,
all sorts of names are
being thrown around. Well,
one thing that happened in the fight there
was undeniable is that Connor started
to fade and we've talked about this,
the endurance issue. Like what,
what do you think is that
issue? Well, it certainly in,
in that fight you could see and what I
learned about it was just brilliant to
watch Floyd how he managed his energy.
I think it's one punch in round one
and maybe not much more around too.
It was just so, you know, it's
such an amazing strategy. And then,
and then switching from the usual style
to kind of does hands up and walk in and,
and Connor did on load a lot on his forms.
Very inefficient,
which is the opposite of what I would
describe Connors fighting style.
These efficient, very few
shots, maximum return.
This was a lots of pointers and it was
one of the few bits of advice I gave them
in the corner that was of any use because
I'm not a boxing guy was let's pick
our show that there's a reason
why he's not telling anything.
You don't try anything.
This is 12 rounds.
It's almost like this tree parts to a
fight as one to forward his five to uh,
Asian. Then there's nine to 12 and fly
just worked that beautifully and it'd be
something that we would definitely do a
lot more if we were to ever get an order
boxing fight. It was recognized that
as 12 rounds pace yourself. He was,
he was kind of in the MNA mode of
just big shots and late the guy up,
but Floyd's the best in
the world not being lit up.
Do you think it's a pacing issue and not
an endurance issue? I think it's both.
Um, but specifically for the
boxing. Yeah, it was, it was,
there was pacing and
endurance in a new field.
No clench work at all. We had a few
little kind of funny clinch techniques.
We were going to try and hammer fist
to the back of the head. There was a,
well he was aiming for the decided ahead.
It was supposed to be
like at the Aina Week.
We played around with little
stretches of the rule.
Then we'd see what joker Taser pulls up
on and could we do little, you know I,
I'm a a chunk are fine as well and you
need comes from wrestling and you see him
doing kind of what almost looked
like arm drags and, and, and,
and tie ups and stuff.
So we were trying to use that and
we've just got broke every time we'd,
we had very little opportunity to kind of,
you know,
even going towards the back and holding
the hip and hit me with one hand.
I couldn't find anything in the written
rules that there were against that.
But we were pulled on the straight away.
So some of the areas where we taught,
we had to rest and, and maybe make Floyd
use energy that he's on use to clinch.
We didn't get that. It was, it was
a media breaks and that's, you know,
that's the sport of boxing, but
that's the Saturdays. So he had,
it would have to be all those,
all those types of adjustments.
One of the more fascinating rumors was
that there was going to be some sort of a
striking match in the octagon
that is with MMA gloves.
It's being talked about it, it was being
talked about is being talking about.
That's been going around as
well, Dan about that and he
said it was horseshit. Oh,
okay. Well I don't deal with, you had
heard about this. I had heard of it.
Who's talking to you about it?
You know,
speaking with Connor and springs
Manga to talk about like the,
you can only throw leg kicks but
taxing. That would be the end. Yeah.
I mean especially Lloyd, the, the site,
the site and Stan says,
you know what,
it's like if you get a leg kick and that
way you must face straight on so you
can check layer cakes. If they
allowed leg kicks and only leg kicks,
no head kicks. Connor would fuck
him up hundred percent quickly.
100% it would be the first cake.
No one even understands it'd
be the first leg kick. Yeah.
Now I will say right away that Connor,
absolutely it doesn't want to do that.
He wants to fight UFC
rules or boxing rules.
Oh zero interest in the high
reflects just that alone.
A hybrid fight. Just
leg kicks alone. Yeah,
he would fuck Floyd Mayweather up. Doesn't
even want to fuck Floyd Mayweather up.
He does but, but within one of
the two wheel sets it doesn't,
he just thinks it's just let
them throw like just a few.
I mean it doesn't matter what fucking
stands Floyd stands in either inside leg
cakes, outside leg kicks. Just one
of those. It would be like we've,
we've allowed to Ireland is we have very
good boxing history and I'm very good
athletes and we get the odd time and a
good boxer will come down for spar and
you know,
these guys can take shots all day long
and wound leg kick and Dave wrong.
You know, it's such a pain
that they've never felt before.
You know, like you said,
it just, it changes
everything very, very quickly.
It would change Floyd's entire game.
He has no idea.
Do you remember what cool Vince
Phillips fought Masato in Japan? No.
When Vince Phillips is at the top
of his game, when he was, you know,
a real elite boxer,
it was just starting to slide and he
went over and fought Masato and k one and
Masato just for tis legs up.
Sure as fuck those legs up.
It was horrifying to watch.
The only one that I remember that
went over there, and actually,
oh, Shannon cannon, Channon and
Cannon Shannon Briggs fought,
uh,
Tom Erickson and Tom Erickson cracked him
with a couple of leg kicks and Shannon
actually talked about it on
the podcast. He's like, champ.
He kept me with a couple of those
leg kicks. I was ready to quit champ.
He was like, it hurts so bad. She
goes, but I'm pretending. He goes,
I'm pretending today ain't nothing.
He goes, I'm in agony chair.
It's just a different pain.
It's a stomachs.
You can get whacked in the head all
day long and most fighters won't even
recognize that, but the right body
shot, you know he hit that liver or,
or the right leg kick and
there's just no grit and true.
It's stunning for people that
have never been kicked before.
It's stunning to watch
WWE. They're like, what?
This happens all the time and if
you watch like a k one match or a,
you know,
a glory match or Moy Tai,
it's just crazy how often they get kicked
and they just learn how to absorb it.
They learn how to check it and
eat it and it just takes time.
But that would,
that would be if you could somehow or
another talk Conor and Floyd into a boxing
match with leg kicks.
Did Floyd actually say that?
That would be something to consider.
It was just one of those,
while I'm talking to Connor,
you'd regularly throw stuff at me.
Then I'm just like, what the hell
are you talking? I mean there's,
I'm always having weird conversation and
this was just one of them where it come
up that there's a possibility. It
is. And they were talking about it,
hybrid rules and he shut it down
straight away. You'll find them.
You'll find them, obviously eat and
when they, it would be of course, ideal.
I think Floyd is a very intelligent guy.
He's not that good,
absolute intelligent guy.
He's not going to do that.
I don't even think you would do the
leg kick. I don't think so wider.
I think he flirts with a lot
of this stuff and I'll, yeah,
I'll come over to your world, but he's,
no, he's no fool. He's a super smart guy.
I just can't imagine that he would spar
with one guy and eat one of those kicks
and he was just like, oh,
fuck this. Fuck all that.
It changes the way you're
allowed to stand. Yes.
I mean he would have to be
very light on his front leg.
You'd have to learn how
to condition his shins.
I mean it's like the whole
thing would be different,
but they have talked about some sort
of a rematch inbox. It's like I said,
it's just one of those things that's
thrown out there and hear a bit of a movie
role and you hear this and this
and that and the, you know,
Connor has the world at his feet are so
many people want to pull them in so many
different ways,
but he seems to have avoided some of
the more obvious Hollywood type traps,
you know, because like Rhonda Rousey
got sucked into all of them, right?
She was doing everything.
She was all these TV shows and movies
and I remember before she lost a Holly
Holm thinking, God, she's getting
stretched thin. Like this can't be good.
This can't be good. You know, and
I was worried about Amanda Nunez.
Amanda Nunez was the one that I
thought had, Ron does number. I'm like,
that girl punches so fucking hard.
And she's an elite ground specialist
and like it wouldn't be a picnic on the
ground. And Rhonda, you know, takes
girls to the ground and submits them.
But it was like, but you got to get
through the fire. That's Amanda Nunez,
his hands.
And I remember seeing her and all these
other things and these television shows
and these movie deals and I was like,
those things will rob you.
They rob you, you, they give you,
they give you something to give you
some money to give you some fame.
You walk that red carpet, you look
wonderful. Smile Ronda, look over here,
smile Connor.
But they steal things from you.
They steal your ability to actually fight.
They steal your ability to,
to have all of your resources.
And Connor's done an amazing
job of avoiding that for
the most part. I mean he's,
you know, it was proper 12 whiskey coming
out and that photo shoots, you know,
had to be done. And um,
but no movies, the movies,
the movies are the ones that really
fucking rob you. Yeah. Yeah. You actually,
you had a small part in the movie when
he was, when he was just starting off 18,
19 is the large movie,
20 things a little head and
he played a prisoner. Um, but yeah, uh,
yeah, he's, because he's obsessed
with finding, he loves fighting.
He was beautiful.
You could see in the lead up to this,
he didn't want to do and
much, much, you know,
media and press and the camps
in agreement we'll be doing.
He'd rather do none of it
and have no buildup. If you,
Conner is ideal world I think
would be the fight in every UFC.
Every Saturday night.
That'll be as ideal.
Just live near the UFC and fight Saturday
night and then have a fun night Sunday
and then get ready for the next site.
We loved fighting like what
else did you do? And like I,
I scratch my head about this.
If I had done my eye [inaudible] gauge
or it could be even though, thank you.
I'm good.
He wants to get right back in.
He wants or fight Floyd and
definitely the heavy one is, that's,
that's the, that's the fire. If you had to
guess what's next, what would you think?
Um, you know, I,
I won't pretend to understand the business
side of things in Adi empowered on
date.
They do all a dad and you know,
the fans so much and the officials
decide and who gets the next shot. I,
I'm a, I only deal with what, you know,
what's going to be put in front of me.
I think it will be the, it'd be rematched
rematch. I think it will be that.
Now I'll be getting torn apart and
it isn't there. This and this guys,
I'm only saying what I think is it going
to be someone else will be, you know,
I don't really know, but that's
what I see him talking about me.
So that's how my mind is.
What do you think will be different in
terms of the way he approaches it in
terms of like trash talking
and all that other stuff.
He's never gonna to not be him. That's,
that's the side of his personality,
you know? And you know, it's a, it's
a dividing line in my, you know,
my parents are not mad about it and it,
but the kids are my gym lover, you know?
It's just what it does.
It's just one of those things.
Corners never knock on to do that.
That's, that's like in Dublin, Eh,
you know, we're, we're where he's from.
There's always that guy in the class
that was just sharp wit, you know,
had the quick reply.
And from the moment I met him,
he was just that guy that's just like,
you can't make a tiny mistake around you,
make you feel stupid very quick, you know?
Uh, yeah, I've been on the end of it.
Um,
but I remember going to it,
I remember that guy in school as well
and it just happens that he has it,
you know, Leetal left hand on top of
that and then he has the look and he,
he just an unusual package that it,
that it all came together. So I don't,
you know, they build up
pretty astute. He didn't stop.
It wasn't like he was going to go, oh, I
hope I don't lose this time. And you know,
he went through the same kind of mindset
he had and I've known that he would go
into that fight that's fully prepared
as we can and he'd be 100% sure in his
mind he's going to destroy me around
because that's how we always think.
If there's another fight that
would sell and it would be huge.
It would be that it would be d
as three or, yeah, that could be.
Especially if Diaz gets passport. Yeah,
yeah. Is he any shit? Even if he doesn't,
I mean just that fight alone.
I mean there's the history
between those two guys.
I mean, that would be, and
it's, it's so appealing
stylistically as well. The fight,
you know, I, I'm a, I'm a
grappler heart, I love grappling,
but I also understand that you do to
turn them a little, put people to sleep.
You know, even if you're into
Jujitsu, it's hard to watch
you to do, to tournament.
Anybody can see a punch hitting someone
in the head and then falling down.
That's, you know, that's exciting.
And Him and Diaz is such a
great personality match up.
It's such a great skill clash.
You know,
if I was the design somebody that's
going to bring the best ever corner,
you'd want someone that,
you know,
can hit back and take a big shot
and put up at the trash. It's a,
it's a beautiful fight. I, I, I always,
I would love to see that rematch. Yeah.
The thing about Dia's when they first
fought was that he didn't give a fuck
about trash talk. It didn't bother him
at all. It was normal. It was like, oh,
okay, we're doing this. Yeah. Yeah. It
was brilliant. It was amazing. It was,
it was what everybody
wanted to see at the time.
It's because Tom Connor was so good at
talking shit and people would get so
flustered,
but then Diaz didn't give a fuck.
And you could tell he didn't give a fuck.
It was just so normal for him.
And it was like, wow, trash talk doesn't
work on Diaz really doesn't work.
Like I had known about some of his train
and partners and, and he's like, Connor,
like in the gym, he's dressed
shogun. Those butter your trash.
I knew every sparing. It's because
it's fun, you know, it's always just,
you know, when we have a con
or having a big spar, you know,
at the gym will be packed down.
Everybody wants to come down and see in
the spine and just see, you know, he's,
he's talking to the guy had a hallway.
True.
Whether it's a close friend like RFM or
whether it's someone we brought in that
he doesn't know, it's not going
to change them. You know, I'll be,
I certainly don't inspiring,
but it will roll room it and even trash
talk me when I'm trying to do my Jesus
shut up. But it's, you know, it's
just, it's, it's his personality.
So what timeline or do you think we're
looking at in terms of his return?
If you had to guess?
It was funny,
I was looking at a March 16th is Patty's
Day is March 17th that's a Sunday.
March 16th was a Saturday.
Oh. Imagine like Msg. I'm the,
the Saturday night before Paddy's
Day. Oh my God. That'd be insane.
I wonder if it's not booked.
Yeah,
I was actually going to go on and
she's booked pretty far in advance.
I had imagined, so I'd invite in. So,
and they're doing one in November
to do two at MSG and a year.
I think you could do Connor in there
every weekend and it's going to bed.
You could also do the Diaz
every weekend and it's gonna be,
it's gonna be packed out. You could do
the TD garden in Boston too. Yeah, yeah.
We've had fucking Irish in Boston.
More Irish in Boston than there.
And you could do of course,
Vegas and Vegas and gamble, but it
just, I saw that date. But um, you know,
like you said, there's the big summer
card as well and you have to fight week.
Did you light July card? Um,
I, I think probably summer,
next summer is probably realistic. You
know, we have to obviously see what, what,
what punishment hippy gets hope.
It's not alone.
I'm not sure. I mean, everybody was so
amped up after the fact that I, you know,
I was like, Oh man, this could be
terrible. But Monday morning I'm like,
Eh, the fuck happened. Really?
Nobody died. Nobody even got cut.
A couple of people got punched in
a place where people get punched.
You know what I mean? It's like, no, I
have to go to her hat and that I am like,
I have a big commercial
gym. I coach kids, I, I'm,
I'm head president of the amateur
MMA association back home.
I deal with politicians all the time
and this is the exact thing that they're
arguing with me or you know,
when I'm,
when I'm wearing a suit on a Wednesday
meeting with the Minister for Sport,
I'm not,
so I'm looking at the own great.
That's what's to be brought up at my
next meeting when I'm trying to get
governing body a status for, for
my, for my life's work, my, my art,
my sport,
and I'm trying to tell plus 60 year
olds that this is legitimate and they're
showing me this and you're, you
know, so for that it was terrible.
You know, there's no other way around
it. Like I said, if, if it was it,
if it had be better done that isolated,
I didn't think it was that big a deal.
They need it, that big a deal. He
didn't really hit Dylan and the,
a bit of pushing and pulling
nothing. Who Cares? You Man.
Coming up and hitting it was
absolutely dangerous. You know,
he's a trained fighter, he bare
knuckles and he's, you know,
hitting a guy who's tired,
who's done hard rounds,
who's taken some headshots and he, you
know, we went for the illegal shot.
You know, there's a reason why you're not
let it to the stem at a brain there. Um,
there has to be something that,
there has to be ramifications for that.
It can't be just like God or hitting
each other and you cannot allow that to
happen again. No, no. And, and I,
an example has to be made so that order
flow people in, in the height of it go,
wait a second.
It's not just a slap on the wrist.
Something substantial happens if you
do something criminal and you know,
it's the salt. Yeah, it literally is.
And I really worry about him in terms
of him having a visa and being able to
obtain a visa and fight in America again.
And I believe he was supposed
to be fighting next month.
Do we find out who that guy
was? He did. Right. Well, I
know what it starts with. A,
Z. One of them was the guy that, uh, Artem
was going to fight in three weeks time.
Okay. Let me read it.
Yeah, that's the guy.
That's the guy. He was actually
bragging about it on a social media.
How do you say Zhou Zhou?
Barea talk who go to the other constantly
and Islam market share face UFC acts
as Conor McGregor ringing.
Attackers reveal. Yeah.
Zuberi I don't know how to say his name.
I'm sorry.
I think he's the one that was wearing red
that jumped the cage and a and punched
Connor bare knuckle Islam market. Gee,
he's the one that hopped over the right.
Did, that happened right in front of me.
Yeah. I think that was him in the red.
I thought that was in the black that
Haman and Connor had a little exchange and
then they get the other
guy hit him from behind.
But I thought that was
going to be market changer.
We're getting him texting to
correct us. Not sure. Yeah.
Uh, either way. Either. That can't happen
again. That stuff, you know, I hope,
I hope it all gets worked out. Um,
well, thank you gentlemen. Thanks.
Thanks for being here at George. Thank
you for illuminating the very elusive art
cutting and it's, uh, it was an excellent
conversation. You're all dipped out now,
huh?
Cognitive ability by
about 200% does it dip?
Increases your cognitive ability, but
200% wireless truck drivers. So stupid.
You know, truck drivers listening right
now. Fuck you joke folks. Just to show,
that's what I do about my people. Let's
say 80% of the stats are made up on the,
on the spot. That's what I'm all about
making shit. And thank you John. Really,
really appreciate you coming
in here really was a lot
of fun and hopefully we'll
do it again under a brighter times.
It's just sport. It is. Of course,
just for, I really appreciate that.
Thank you. Thank you everybody.
Yeah.